Rồi các bạn đầu tiên thì mình rất là xin
lỗi các bạn là hôm qua mình vừa chút
việc riêng nên là mình không có qua
chúng ta cũng không có học được nay
chúng ta học bình thường các bạn nhá.
Cái buổi chuột tuần trước chúng ta đang
dừng lại ở giở đạ chúng ta đang bắt đầu
cái quá trình chúng ta xây dựng cái
script để có thể huấn luyện cái mô hình
dành cho bài toán text classification
trong bảng NLP đúng không? Chúng ta cũng
mới bắt đầu thôi đúng không? Chúng ta
cũng mới làm cái gì nhở? Chúng ta bắt
đầu chúng ta đầu tiên là cái file dữ
liệu đã. Mở lại cái file dữ liệu nhá.
File rượu nó là như này
đây.
Mở lại một chút nhá. Mở lại một chút
này.
Chờ một tí các bạn nhá. Chạy cái file nó
hơi nói nặng chút.
Rồi các bạn nhìn này đúng không? Đây là
rượu chúng ta sau khi chúng ta mở ra đây
nó như thế này đúng không? Chúng ta có
sáu cột. Cột job đây là cột về đây là bộ
rượu về job đúng không? Mỗi một hàng mỗi
một row là một job đúng không? Chúng ta
có các cái cột ví dụ như là cột cột
title cột location đúng không? Title
này, location này, description này,
function này, industry này với ở care
level đúng không? Thì nhiệm vụ chúng ta
là gì? thì chúng ta xây dựng cái mô hình
để làm sao để sau này có những cái job
mới chúng ta biết thông tin về title,
location, description, function,
industry. Chúng ta muốn cái mô hình
chúng ta nó có thể dưỡn được xem là cái
job này nó thuộc về cái level nào đúng
không? Nhiệm vụ đơn giản như vậy thôi.
Đây mình gọi là bài toán text
classification hoặc là document
classification. Bài toán phân loại thì
bao giờ cũng là bài toán cơ bản nhất
trong mọi mảng đúng không? Chúng ta sau
này các bạn nào các bạn đã học về mảng
compation các bạn cũng sẽ có bài toán cơ
bản nhất là bài toán image
classification phân loại bao giờ cũng là
bài toán cơ bản nhất. Đấy
thế thì hôm nọ chúng ta mới làm gì?
Chúng m chúng ta mới chỉ đầu tiên chúng
ta đọc dựa vào đúng không? Chúng ta ờ
loại bỏ bớt những cái hàng nó bị nó có
những cái dòng nó bị nan đúng không? Bộ
này chúng ta có một có đúng một sle là
bị nan thôi. Chúng ta sẽ drop nó luôn
đúng ít quá thì chúng ta drop nhiều
chúng ta mới phải cân nhắc xem cho điền
kiểu gì đúng không? Sau chúng ta tách dữ
liệu theo chiều dọc theo chiều ngang
được chưa? Và chúng ta cũng đã tiền xử
lý cái cột title đúng không? Chúng ta
dùng TFIDF vectorizer.
TF IDF vectorizer là như thế này.
Nó cũng giống như những cái các bạn dùng
ví dụ như là standard scal, one hot,
onhot min max scaler rồi là các bạn dùng
onhot encoding nó cũng y chang như vậy.
Nó tức là gì? Chúng ta cũng sẽ có những
cái method như là fit này, transform với
cả fit transform đúng không? Tiếp vizer
nó sẽ giúp chúng ta có thể tách các cái
văn bản ra thành các cái token đúng
không? Ờ mặc định là nó sẽ chỉ tách là
các bạn chỉ dùng ờ unigram thôi đúng
không? Chúng ta có một cái giá trị là
range này mặc định là các bạn chỉ có
unigram thôi. Được chưa? Nếu mà các bạn
thay đổi cái giá trị max v các bạn sẽ có
nhiều hơn. Còn nếu không các bạn để mặc
định 11 nó chỉ unigram. Được chưa? Ờ
đúng không? Chúng ta ở đây mình không có
thay đổi cái gì cả. mình dùng những cái
mặc định cả đúng không? Tất cả những cái
mình dùng mặc định cả. Được chưa? Và sau
khi mình xử lý xong, sau khi mình xử lý
xong thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó nó là một
cái output chúng nó sẽ là một cái ma
trận kích thước rất là lớn. Số hàng thì
bằng số hàng thì bằng số lượng sample
còn số cột là bằng kích thước của cái
vocabulary khi chúng ta sử dụng TF IDF.
Được chưa? Vocabulary chúng ta nó sẽ ờ
đây này. Đúng không? 6000 khoảng 6500
hàng với cả từng này cột đúng không? Nếu
mà chúng ta nếu mà chúng ta muốn xem nó
dưới dạng là một cái
một cái ma trận ấy thì cũng được. Chúng
ta sẽ sẽ bọc nó vào trong một cái data
frame của Pandas. Đ ví dụ các bạn muốn
xem nó dạng ma ma trận nhá. Thì mình sẽ
bọc này.
Ờ data
rồi data
này đúng không? Nếu muốn bọc lại như này
như thế này được chưa?
Chạy nhá. Chạy thế này đúng không? Mình
bọc cái data frame lại này.
Từ tắt này đã
nhá. Như này
nó sẽ một cái mặt trận rất là thưa. Phần
lớn các phần tử nó vẫn bằng 0 thôi. Nó
chỉ có một một số ít các cái phần tử nó
bằng nó có giá trị khác 0 đúng không?
TFDF nó vẫn nó vẫn thưa đúng không? Chờ
một tí này.
Đây cái output như thế này nhá.
Ơ
các bạn à
các bạn chờ chờ mình một chút mình mình
quên cái cú pháp các bạn chờ tí nhá.
Ờ
các bạn chờ một tí nhá.
phát
convert
data frame
này
tí nhá
thêm
bạn chờ một tí nhá. Thầy quên mất cái cú
pháp.
Ờ
ok. Đây
nhá. Thêm một dọc nữa nhá.
Ê này
rồi DF này cũng được nhá. Đạy thử lại
này.
Mình tắt cái mình tắt cái
mình tắt cái câu ở đây nên là nó không
có hỏi thẳng ở đây được. Pte ra ngoài
rồi đây nhá. DF của mình nhá. Đây các
bạn nhìn này. Lại trông như thế này đây
các bạn thấy không? Nó là một cái bài
nhật nó rất là thưa đúng không? Nó sẽ có
hơn 6000 hàng đúng không? Và nó sẽ có
khoảng hơn 2000 cột. Đây hơn a bao nhiêu
cột đấy nhỉ?
À nó sẽ có 3013 cột. Các bạn thấy chưa?
Mỗi một hàng nó là một cái một cái một
cái simple đúng không? Một cái job. Mỗi
một cột là những ch những cái từ trong
cái những cái token trong vocabulary của
chúng ta này. Được chưa? Đấy nó sẽ rất
là thưa đúng không? Chỉ có một vài phần
tử đây các bạn không? Thì thoảng lắm các
bạn nhìn mình có phân tử nó khác không
thôi đúng không? Tì title nó title nó
ngắn mà title nó rất là ngắn đúng không?
Nó có ít từ được chưa? Đấy là cái title
của chúng ta. Chúng ta dùng TF IDF để xử
lý đúng không? TF IDF được chưa? Đây cái
title. Thì bây giờ thì bây giờ title thì
xong rồi đúng không? Chúng ta số hóa
rồi. Thế bây gi chúng ta sẽ nói về các
cái các cái cột các cột tiếp theo các
cái feature tiếp theo.
Sau title chúng ta sẽ có về location các
bạn. Các bạn nhìn thử xem location xem
chúng ta nên xử lý nào nhá.
Chờ một tí này.
Đây nhá. Location như này đây. Cột
location này. Đấy. Nó như này.
Theo các bạn theo các bạn cái cột
location này chúng ta sẽ tiền xì nó như
thế nào? Để nguyên này chắc là máy nó
không hiểu rồi đúng không? để nguyên này
đưa vào máy. Máy nó không hiểu. Thế bây
giờ phải tiền xỉ nó như thế nào? Bây giờ
theo các bạn tiền xí theo cách nào thì
phù hợp?
TF IDF
ừ
dùng cả singular value decomposition. Ừ
hơi phức tạp nhở. Ừ. Ok. TFDF xong nó
dùng chancetate singular value
decomposition.
hơi hơi phức tạp một chút. Hơi phức tạp.
Có cách nào mà chúng ta dùng những thứ
chúng ta đã học cho nó dễ không các bạn?
Colcation có cái cách nào nó nó dễ thở
hơn một tí không?
Theo các bạn
à
>> dùng gì cơ?
Dùng gì nhỉ? Mình chưa nghe rõ.
Nó hơi bị có thể viết được không? Viết
không? Mình mình nghe không rõ lắm.
Mình vẫn chưa nghe được cái gì cả. Hay
là có lẽ là viết đi nào các bạn. Cái cod
location các bạn xử lý nào? Bây giờ để
nguyên này máy nó không có hiểu đâu.
Location để nguyên máy nó không hiểu.
>> Có location này làm thế nào vậy các bạn?
Các bạn mà các bạn mà không xử lý được
chỉ có nước bỏ thôi. Đấy để nguyên này
đưa vào mô hình nó sẽ lỗi ngay. Nếu mà
không xử lý được là chỉ có bỏ thôi.
Năm nào bây giờ?
Ồ qua một tuần thôi là chúng ta thành
người mới hết rồi các bạn. Qua một tuần
thôi là chúng ta thành new hết à.
Không ai xử lý được này.
Tách ra tách như nào? Tách tách cái gì?
Tách như thế nào? Bây giờ
tách ra thì cũng phải xử lý đúng không?
Tách ra thì vẫn là thứ máy nó không có
hiểu được đúng không? Tách ra ý bạn tách
cái phần trước dấu phẩy về sau dấu phẩy.
Tách ra xong thì cũng phải xử lý thôi
đúng không? Tách ra xong nó vẫn là chữ
mà đúng không? Máy nó vẫn không hiểu
được. Xem nào bây giờ?
On hot là một cách đúng không các bạn
thấy không? On hot là một cách đúng
không? On hot là một cách chúng ta hãy
thử là on hot với cả cụm này đi đúng
không? Trước khi tách chúng ta hãy thử
on hot với
cả đi đúng không? Hot cả đi đúng không?
Đây các bạn nh nó có cái cấu trúc là tên
thành phố rồi phẩy rồi mã của cái bang
đấy đúng không? Mỹ nó có 50 bang đúng
không? Tên thành phố phẩy mã bang đúng
không? Thử dùng onh đi đúng không? Thử
one hot đi xem. xem nó như nào đúng
không? Thử dùng đi đúng không? Bây giờ
nếu mà muốn dùng onhot nhá đúng không?
Thì bây giờ chúng ta lại gọi cái đấy lại
cách cũ thôi đúng không? For kit learn.
Processing này import onhot này. Được
chưa? On chúng ta dùng rồi mà đúng
không? Có phải chúng ta chưa dùng bao
giờ đâu các bạn. On hot dùng dùng chán
dê rồi đúng không? On hot này thì bây
giờ chúng tôi sẽ tôi sẽ không dùng cái
vectorizer này nữa. Dùng onhot được
chưa?
Encoder bằng con encoder này được chưa?
Encoder tôi sẽ mã hóa cho c location
location này. Được chưa? Nó phải là mặc
hai chiều
chưa? Mình sẽ in cái print
outputsap.
Được chưa? Chạy thử nhá.
in là cái output. Shp này nhá.
Đây cái shap của nó số hàng thì dễ hiểu
đúng không? Nó là số lượng số lượng
sample trong cái bộ tren thôi. Chả có gì
đặc biệt cả. Giống y trang vừa nãy thôi
đúng không? Số hàng thì muôn đời như
này. Số cột là 955 55 đúng không?
Các bạn thấy thế nào?
Các bạn thấy nào?
Hơi nhiều đúng. Nó hơi nhiều đúng không?
Với One, chỗ này nó hơi nhiều hot thường
ta dùng dưới 100. Thông thường one hot
mà các bạn tạo ra ph dưới 100 thì ok
đúng không? Cái này dùng thì vẫn được
nhưng mà nó nó tốn tài nguyên quá và nó
nó thưa quá. Nó thưa quá đúng không?
Thế bây giờ theo các bạn, bây giờ theo
các bạn là bây giờ tôi muốn
nó nhiều quá thì bây giờ nên là giả sử
bây giờ tôi vẫn muốn dùng one hot mà tôi
muốn giảm bớt số lượng feature đi. Đây
95 nhiều quá nhiều feature quá tôi muốn
giảm bớt đi
thì tôi làm thế nào bây giờ? Muốn giảm
bớt thì tôi làm thế nào bây giờ?
muốn giảm bớt số feature làm nào bây giờ
tách bang và city thì cũng là một cách
nhưng các bạn cứ thử các bạn cứ thử hình
dung nhá các bạn có tách vào và vào city
ra đấy thì cái bang ok nó bang có thể mỹ
nó chỉ có
ở ba
các bạn tưởng tượng nhá các bạn tách ra
ấy có thể là cột bang thì ừ thì nó chỉ
chắc là Mỹ nó cũng chỉ có 50 bang thôi
đúng không nhưng mà CT nó vẫn sẽ cứ
nhiều đúng không các Bạn tách ra thì cái
city nó nó vẫn cứ nhiều mà đúng không?
955 này nhiều là nhiều là do City chứ
không phải nhiều do bang đúng không? Cái
số này nhiều là do CT chứ không phải là
do bang. Tại vì sao? Tại vì là thông
thường thông thường một CT nó chỉ gắn
với một bang thôi chứ làm gì có chuyện
một CT lại nằm ở trong hai bang đâu đúng
không? Các bạn tách ra thì các bạn bớt
được. Ok. Cái phần mã bang có thể nó nó
nó ít nhưng mà cái mã VCD nó vẫn cứ
nhiều mà đúng không? Tách ra có vẻ là
không ổn đúng không? Nó tách ra số lượng
thành phố nó vẫn thế mà nó đâu có bớt đi
ông ông nào đâu đúng không? Nhiều mã
nhiều cái này nhiều cái giá trị khác
nhau là do cái sạch sằng CT chứ không
phải do thằng Bang.
Ừ chả liên quan tagit encoder nghe cái
tên đã thấy không liên quan rồi. Tget
encoder hoặc gọi là label encoder là
label cho cái cho cái cột target. Đây có
phải tagit đâu. Đây là feature mà không
liên quan đúng không? Chẳng liên quan
nào bây giờ mọi người thử nghĩ xem. Bây
giờ ok. Giả sử bây giờ mình muốn dùng
hot đi nhưng mà nó nhiều quá.
Nó nhiều quá đúng không? Nó nhiều quá.
Cái location nhiều giá trị quá.
On hot tạo ra nhiều quá. Bây giờ tôi
muốn co bớt đi thì tôi làm thế nào?
Co bớt nhưng mà nó phải hợp lý các bạn
nhá. Chứ không phải là tôi cứ muốn co
bớt mà tôi ờ tôi tìm mọi cách đâu đúng
không? Tôi giảm bớt số lượng feature đi
nhưng mà nó cũng phải hợp lý một chút
đúng không? Có cách nào theo các bạn?
Cách dễ nhất là chúng ta là làm như nào?
Làm thế nào bây giờ?
Làm nào bây giờ?
Làm nào?
B các bạn thử nhá. Thế ví dụ này, bây
giờ mình lập luận là gì? Cái bộ rượu này
là bộ rượu về job đúng không? Bộ rượu về
job.
Thì bây giờ mình có thể lập luận là gì?
Mình lập luận là
các cái thành phố trong vùng 1 bang mình
có thể lập luận là gì? Là có thể có thể
là cái mặt yêu cầu về mặt kinh nghiệm nó
sẽ xê xêm nhau đúng không? Các thành phố
trong cụng 3 thì vị trí đị nó gần nhau
thì mình có thể lập luận là gì? Là có
thể là yêu cầu về về cái mức độ thành
thạo công việc nó là như nhau. Thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ tôi sẽ làm gì? Thì bây giờ
tôi sẽ co nó về thay vì tôi để chia
thành từng thành phố này. Tôi sẽ chỉ lấy
cái mã mã bang thôi. Được chưa? Chỉ lấy
mã bang tức là gì? Tôi nhìn chung tôi sẽ
chỉ lấy hai ký tự cuối cùng thôi. Nếu nó
là ký tự của mã ba. Tất nhiên nó sẽ có
một cái bà trường ngoài đệ. Ví dụ đây
new này nó thiếu đúng không? Nó thiếu
cái mã bang. Thì một là các bạn có thể
dùng rượu bên ngoài các bạn điền vào đây
là xem là những cái chỗ mà thiếu này nó
điền như thế nào đúng không? Hoặc là có
những cái chỗ nó chỉ ghi chung là nước
Mỹ thôi. Ví dụ đây không
Psyania này đúng không? Cũng thiếu mất
cái mã bang này. Một là các bạn dùng dữ
liệu bên ngoài các bạn điền vào xem nó
mã bang là gì. Hai là các bạn để nguyên
đúng không? Ví dụ thành phố nào mà thiếu
ba tôi để nguyên nó còn ông nào có thì
tôi
ra đúng không? Hoặc là đây các bạn nh có
những job nó trên toàn nước Mỹ này đúng
không? Đấy thì những cái trường hợp này
tôi sẽ tôi sẽ để nguyên được chưa? Tất
nhiên ở đây như mình nói rồi cái việc mà
tôi giảm vớt số lượng feature này tôi
phải có một cái lập luận gì đấy mà mà nó
make sense đúng không? Chứ không phải là
vì tôi muốn giảm bớt số lượng feature
nên tôi giảm nên tôi gộp bằng mọi cách
đúng không? Ở đây mình gộp tại vì mình
mình lập luận là gì? là cái thành vô
trong vùng 3 thì yêu cầu công việc nó
xêm xêm nhau đúng không? Đấy thì mình sẽ
mình sẽ dựa vào cái logic này đúng
không? Thì mình sẽ chỉ lấy tức là gì?
Nếu mà hai ký tự cuối nó thực sự nó là
mã của cái bang đấy thì à tức nó là mã
bang đúng không? Thì tôi sẽ lấy nó ra.
Còn nếu mà hai kự cuối không phải đây
USA tôi sẽ lấy cả đúng không? Hoặc là
đây Pania tôi cũng lấy cả đúng. Tất
nhiên bình thường là chúng ta nên là
chúng ta sẽ tự điền. Tức chúng ta sẽ
điền vào đây chúng ta xem là cái cái
bảng cái danh danh sách cái thành phố
của Mỹ xem nó là cái bang nào chúng ta
điền vào. Nhưng mà đây ví dụ mình không
có thì mình coi như mình lấy lấy nguyên
cái từ gốc này thôi. Được chưa
nào các bạn? Thì bây giờ ấy để kiểm tra
xem là để kiểm tra xem là hai cái kịch
tử cuối ở đây ấ nó có thực sự nó là cái
mã A3 hay không thì theo các bạn chúng
ta làm bằng cách nào?
Làm bằng cách nào?
Nếu chúng ta muốn kiểm tra xem là thực
sự hay của E nó có vẻ mã bao chưa làm
cái nào ạ?
Làm như nào?
Thế á cũng không rõ lắm, cũng không có
thảo lắm vì cái mã bang này. 13 có nhiều
mã
rồi. Nào các bạn quay lại này.
Ừ cũng là một cách đúng không? Nếu mà
tôi bắt được bốn ký tự cuối là gì? Là
dấu phẩy khoảng trắng rồi hai ký tự viết
hoa đúng không? Nếu có dấu phẩy khoảng
tráng hay tự hoa thì đây là mã ba đúng
không? Thông thường các bạn có biết là
muốn bắt cái này người ta hay dùng cái
gì không? Người ta muốn bắt cái này
người ta hay dùng cái gì không các bạn?
Ừ 13 có nhiều zip code thì nghe ok 13 có
nhiều mã thì nghe có vẻ hơi ấy nhỉ.
Nào các bạn thông thường các bạn biết là
khi muốn bắt những cái bắt những cái
thông tin như này người ta hay dùng cái
gì không các bạn? Sau là chúng ta gọi là
cái gì? Đúng rồi. Chúng ta gọi là
regular expression đúng không? Lớp mình
có bạn nào các bạn từng nghe về cái
thuật ngữ regular expression rồi các bạn
cho mình số 1. Nếu bạn nào đây là lần
đầu tiên các bạn nghe thấy các bạn cho
mình số 0 được không?
Rồi thế
có những bạn chưa nghe thấy thì mình nói
nói qua nhanh nhá. Thế nào gọi là
regular expression? Regular expression
nó là đây viết nhá. Regular expression.
Regular
expression như này. Được chưa? Regular
expression là cái gì? Nó kiểu như này. Ờ
regular expression tức là nó là chúng nó
là cái khái niệm chúng ta sẽ chúng ta sẽ
định nghĩa cái mẫu cái pattern cho cái
thứ mà chúng ta muốn bắt nhá. Ví dụ
chúng ta muốn bắt số điện thoại, email,
tên, tuổi các cái thứ. Chúng ta bắt
những cái thông tin này, chúng ta sẽ
định nghĩa xem là một cái email trông nó
như thế nào, một cái số điện thoại trông
nó như thế nào, một cái tên trông nó sẽ
như thế nào. Chúng ta sẽ định nghĩa cái
thứ mà chúng ta muốn bắt nó trông như
thế nào. Và sau đó chúng ta sẽ
bắt những cái thông tin này ra. Mình lấy
ví dụ nhá. Mình lấy ví dụ này. Ví dụ
thông thường cái trang mà để
search nhanh à không phải để search
nhanh mà định nghĩa nhanh cái R
expression thì là nó là cái trang này à
đây trang này mình hay dùng cái trang
này
a không nh không phải không phả no no
not this one à gì ấy nhỉ à đây đây đây
đây đây trang thứ hai đây nhá
mình chì các bạn nhá cái này nó cũng
không khó đâu nó cũng không khó đâu thế
này nhá thế thì bây giờ ấy giả sử mình
có một cái chuỗi đầu vào các bạn thử
mình tìm cái chuỗi đầu vào xem là chỗ
nào thì ok đây nhá. Ví dụ bây giờ mình
có một cái chuỗi như này nhá. Mình có
một cái chuỗi như này. Chỗ tex này được
chưa? Bây giờ ấy mình có chuy text này
đúng không? My phone number is in này
đúng không? My brothers one is như này.
Được chưa? Bây giờ mình muốn bắt được
tất cả các cái số điện thoại trong cái
chuỗi này. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ ấy khi
mà mình sử dụng regular regular
expression thì mình sẽ phải định nghĩa
xem là cái khuôn mẫu của một cái số điện
thoại là nó như thế nào đúng không?
Khuôn mẫu của một cái số điện thoại nó
là nó là như thế nào.
Thế thì bây giờ ấy để dùng được ration ấ
chúng ta sẽ có một cái a đây nó sẽ có
những cái mẫu như này. Cái paton như
này. Đầu tiên này cái ký tự mà phổ biến
nhất cái gì nó cũng bắt được ấy là ký
tự. Tức là trong trường hợp các bạn muốn
bắt tất cả các loại ký tự ngoại trừ ký
tự xuống dòng thì các bạn dùng cái dấu
chấm này. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Dấu chấm
này. Chấm một cái này. Các bạn thấy
chưa? Khi mình chấm một cái thì lập tức
là gì? Lập tức là tất cả các ký tự này
nó đều được bắt. Chữ M, chữ I, dấu
khoảng trắng này, PH các thứ này. Được
chưa? Tất cả các ký tự đều được bắt.
Nhưng mà các bạn thấy này, giữa chúng có
một cái khoảng trắng thìể thể hiện ra
gì? Thì là mỗi ký tự này nó là một kết
quả. Chữ M là một kết quả, chữ I là một
kết quả. Khoảng trắng là một kết quả,
chữ P là một kết quả. Mỗi ông này là một
kết quả khác nhau. Được chưa?
Nhưng mà bắt cái dấu chấm này thì bắt
này chung chung quá đúng không? Chúng ta
thường chúng ta sẽ muốn bắt những thứ nó
cụ thể hơn chứ còn chấm này chung quá.
Được chưa?
Nếu chúng ta muốn bắt các cái ký tự chữ
thì các bạn nhìn này. Chúng ta có cái ký
tự là số W này các bạn. Một là các bạn
click vào đây. Hai các bạn tự gõ vào số
W này các không? Cái số W này ấy nó sẽ
bắt cái gì? Nó sẽ bắt ký tự chữ và số.
Các bạn nhớ không? Đây này. M any word
character mà word đây nó không phải là
chỉ có word đâu. Nó sẽ bắt là gì? Nó là
alpha numeric. Tức là gì? chữ số và cái
dấu gạch chân ở dưới dấu underscore được
chưa? Thì các bạn nhìn này đúng không nó
chỉ bắt đâu khoảng trắng nó không bắt
nữa dấu cộng nó cũng không bắt nữa. Dấu
chấm nó cũng không bắt nó chỉ bắt là chữ
này số hoặc là underscore cái dấu
apostrophe cái dấu sở hữu cách này nó
cũng không bắt luôn đúng không? Đấy nó
chỉ bắt những cái này thôi. Đây là các
bạn bắt chỉ các cái tự chữ số về_. Còn
nếu tôi chỉ muốn bắt cái tự số thôi tôi
có cái xuộc D này. Xuộc D tôi chỉ bắt số
đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Xuộc D này tôi chỉ
bắt số thôi. Đấy được chưa? Nó chỉ bắt
số thôi. Đây các bạn chỉ chuột vào đây.
Chỉ bắt số thôi. Được chưa?
Ờ đây là việc các bạn chỉ ra các bạn
muốn bắt cái ký tự nào? Thế thì bây giờ
nếu mà người ta muốn chỉ bắt chữ thôi
ấy, đúng không? Cái W này là bắt cả chữ
cả số. D là chỉ bắt số thôi. Còn S là
chỉ bắt ký tự khoảng trắng. Khoảng trắng
này. Đấy. Khoảng trắng này. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ á bây giờ ấy tôi muốn bắt
các cái ký tự mà các cái ký tự chữ thôi.
Từ A đến Z thì tôi làm nào? Thì các bạn
có thể làm như này. Đây các bạn nhìn cái
dấu ngoặc ở dưới này. Đây này. A BC.
Đấy, tôi chỉ bắt là A B C D E F GH. Ví
dụ như vậy, tôi chỉ bắt những cái ký tự
này thôi thôi đúng không?
Ờ ví dụ các bạn muốn bắt đủ các cái chữ
cái thì nó chúng ta trong bản tr tiếng
Anh có 26 chữ cái đúng không? A B C D
đây ví dụ như các bạn chỉ ra như này
nhưng mà chỉ này thì nó dài quá đúng
không? Thì ví dụ chúng ta muốn bắt từ A
đến Z chúng ta sẽ viết gọn lại như này A
đến Z này. Được chưa? A đến Z đây tôi
bắt chỉ vị chữ thường thôi. Được chưa?
Đáp án Z là nó phi chữ hoa chữ thường
nhá. Đúng không? Tôi muốn bắt cả chữ in
hoa nữa thì tôi đến Z này. Được chưa? Cả
hoa cả thường được chưa? Không mắt số
nữa đấy.
Nhưng mà từ nãy giờ là mình chỉ bắt một
ký tự đơn lẻ thôi. Tôi muốn bắt nhiều ký
tự tôi làm thế nào? Tôi bắt nhiều ký tự
thì tôi ở dưới tôi có một cái liên quan
đến quantifier. Nó có những cái ký hiệu
đi kèm này. Ví dụ các bạn muốn bắt ký tự
số nhá. Đúng rồi. Đây là số đúng không?
Các bạn nhìn khi mà bắt ký tự số này
đúng không? Thì mỗi cái chữ số này nó là
một kết quả đơn lẻ đúng không? Mỗi chữ
số này nó là một kết quả đơn lẻ. Được
chưa? Thế thì bây giờ á tôi sẽ có thêm
những cái ký hội bên cạnh nữa để tôi có
thể tôi hiển tôi muốn bắt bao nhiêu. Ví
dụ đầu tiên là cái dấu asteric này. Cái
dấu asteric cái gì nhở? Dấu hoa thị đúng
không? Dấu hoa thị. Cái dấu hoa thị này
có nghĩa là gì? Là tôi muốn bắt cái ký
tự a này 0 hoặc là nhiều hơn. Tức là nó
nó có thể xuất hiện 0 lần, một lần, hai
lần, ba lần. Được chưa? Dấu cộng này có
nghĩa là 1 hoặc nhiều hơn. Dấu hỏa chấm
là 0 bằng 1. Ví dụ mình bắt dấu cộng
nhá. Các bạn nhìn khi này đúng không?
Đây là các cái ký tự chữ này nó là mỗi
ông là một kết quả xương lẻ này đúng
không? Nó không có cái sự kết nối với
nhau. Nhấn dấu cộng một cái này. Cộng
một cái này đúng không? Một hoặc nhiều
hơn. Đây này. 49 là một kết quả này. Cả
cái chuỗi này là một kết quả này. Đúng
không? Cả cái chuỗi 012 này nó là một
kết quả này. Thấy chưa? Đấy đúng không?
Thay vì là mỗi ông là là một kết quả
riêng lẻ thì bây giờ chúng ta đã kết nối
chúng lại vào với nhau rồi. Nhau lên
cộng này. Chưa kết nối vào với nhau này.
Đúng không? Thế nhưng mà tất nhiên là số
điện thoại bắt nó không đơn giản như thế
đúng không? Số điện thoại nó còn dụ cái
số điện thoại này nó dễ rồi đúng không?
Nhưng mà đây tôi còn có cái chuỗi này
nữa cơ đúng không? Thì bây giờ ấy cái
khó của pattern của của regular regular
expression là gì? Là làm sao để tôi có
thể tôi định nghĩa một cái khuôn mẫu
chung để nó có thể nó bắt nhiều cái
trường hợp khác nhau. Ví dụ số điện
thoại tậm chí nó có thể có thể có cả dấu
ngoặc nữa đúng không? Nó có nhiều cái
format lắm nó có thể có kiểu ngoặc như
này này. Ngoặc này đấy nó như này này
đúng không? Nó có nhiều format lắm đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà ở đây trường hợp ví
dụ trường hợp đơn giản mình coi như nó
chỉ có hai cái format này thôi đúng
không? Thì bây gi bắt được cái này bây
giờ đúng không? Số điện thoại nó có thể
có dấu cộng hoặc là không đúng không?
Dấu cộng nó có thể xuất hiện một lần
hoặc là 0. Thì đấy chính là cái lúc mà
người ta dùng cái ký tự là 0 hoặc 1 này.
Đây này. Đúng không? Cái dấu hỏi chấm là
0 hoặc 1. Mình bắt đầu thử các bạn nhá.
Ví dụ các cái ký tự đặc biệt ấy thì các
bạn phải có cái dấu suộc đi trước. Các
bạn các bạn muốn bắt dấu cộng ấy các bạn
để cộng này nó sẽ không chạy đâu. Tại vì
dấu cộng này thì nó sẽ bị trùng với cái
quantifier này. Các bạn bắt dấu cộng các
cái dấu suộc ở trước cho các cái ký tự
đặc biệt dấu cộng này, dấu dấu nháy đơn
này, dấu nháy kép này là luôn phải có
một cái dấu xuộc đi trước. Được chưa? Ví
dụ t mình bắt dấu cộng nhạ mình bắt dấu
cộng nhá. Đúng không? Dấu cộng này ấy
thì với số điện thoại ấy nó có thể xuất
hiện 0 hoặc là một lần đúng không? Đây
này. Chỗ này nó b nó xuất hiện một lần
nhưng đây nó chả xuất hiện lần nào đúng
không? Thì tôi muốn chỉ ra là xuất hiện
0 1 là tôi dùng cái dấu hỏi chấm này.
Hỏi chấm nghĩa là 0 hoặc 1 đấy này. Hỏi
chấm này đúng không? Nghĩa là 0 hoặc 1
lần nó sẽ có một cái wing. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì không hoặc một lần tức là nó có
thể nó sẽ có vô số kết quả. Tại vì là
một thì dễ rồi nhưng mà không thì nó
xuất hiện nhiều lắm đúng không? Đây cũng
là một kết quả như vậy đúng không? Đây
cũng đây cũng là xuất hiện không lần mà
đúng không? Từng ký tự này nó kết quả
nhưng mà nó nhiều quá người ta sẽ không
có show ra. Được chưa? Dấu cộng này được
chưa? Sau dấu cộng tôi có để tôi sẽ có
hai ký tự số được chưa? Nếu mà tôi muốn
có cái số cụ thể tôi dùng cái dấu ngoặc
này đúng không? Ví dụ đây này, tôi bắt
chính xác năm lần này hoặc là tôi bắt
hai hoặc nhiều hơn này. Được chưa? Ví dụ
đây mình bắt ký tự số nhá. Ký tự số thì
nó sẽ là d như này. Được chưa? Sau ký tự
dấu cộng rồi. Dấu cộng có thể có 0 hoặc
1. Th tôi bắt đầu bắt một số đúng không?
Một số thì hơi ít đúng không? Tôi sẽ bắt
là tôi bắt hai số. Đây hai số đây. Bắt
hai dấu này. Được chưa? Thế các bạn thấy
không? Những này 01 là một kết quả này.
2 3 các thứ này. Được chưa?
Dấu cộng có thể có thể không này. Hai ký
thự số này. Được chưa? Tiếp theo là cái
khoảng trắng. Khoảng trắng này cũng có
thể có có thể không đúng không? Khoảng
trắng đây là nó có số khoảng trắng này.
Đây là không có đúng không? Thì mình có
thể mình bắt khoảng trắng tiếp này.
Khoảng trắng thì có thể là xộc S này
hoặc là xộc cách cái đều được. Hai cách
đều được đúng không? Dự dụ số S này đi
đúng không? Nó cũng có thể có có thể
không. Mình cho dấu hỏi chấm này. Sau đó
sẽ là một chuỗi số. Một chuỗi số ví dụ
là có tối thiểu là tám số chẳng hạn. Ví
dụ như vậy nó một chuỗi số này được
chưa? Có thể có tám số trở lên thì 8
phẩy một cái này
này. Các bạn nhìn thấy chưa? Ví dụ đây
đúng không? Tôi bắt được cả cái chuỗi
này. Tôi bắt được cái chuỗi này đúng
không? Nhìn nhá. Dấu cộng này có thể có
0 hoặc 1. Được chưa? Có thể có 0 hoặc 1.
Đây là 1, đây là 0. Số có đúng hai số
được chưa? Ờ khoảng trắng có thể có 0
hoặc 1. Được chưa? Và sau đó là tôi sẽ
có tám ký tự số trở lên. Được chưa? Đây
này các bạn nhìn nó thành hai kết quả
này. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ ấy tôi mà
muốn tôi thử đây là tôi test trên web
thôi. Tôi phải paste thử vào trong
Python. Đây nó ghi là JavaScript th các
bạn dùng Python nó cũng nó cũng thế thôi
nhá.
Bây giờ tôi sẽ paste thử vào trong
Python xem là tôi có bắt được không nhá.
Thì bây giờ ví dụ ở trong code mình này
mình tạo ra một cái file example để mình
test thử nhá. Được chưa? Example đây.
Xóa bớt đi được chưa nhá. Thì bây giờ ấy
muốn dùng được cái regular expression ấy
thì trong Python nó có một cái thư viện
riêng nó tên là RE. Re của Regular
Expression như này được chưa? Regular
expression. Thế thì bây gi
của tôi đây này. Đây chỗ đầu vào đây
này. Được chưa? Đấy như này. Thế thì bây
giờ tôi sẽ dùng level exation thì tôi sẽ
là out này bằng r cái hàm là file on.
File on là tìm hết đấy. Được chưa? File
on tìm hết. Cái hàm file on này tôi sẽ
phải chỉ ra là đầu tiên tôi chỉ ra cái
mẫu của tôi. Cái pattern là cái mà các
bạn vừa định nghĩa ấy. Thứ hai là cái
string này. Thứ hai cái string. Cái
string cái input đầu vào đấy các bạn
nhìn nhá. Cái pattern của mình này.
Bằng cái gì?
bằng cái đây đây được chưa?
Đây
pattern cái này gọi cái gì nhỉ? Gọi là
string đúng không? String
string bằng xin được chưa? Sau đó mình
sẽ chạy thôi. Prin này result nhá các
bạn nhìn này.
Ok rồi đây này. Được chưa? Bắt được hai
chuỗi rồi. Được chưa? Đây là về số điện
thoại. Các bạn muốn bắt về email thì
cũng tương tự như thế không? Email cũng
y chang chả khác gì cả.
Các đệ trời lên đâu
đâu có bỏ đâu. Có bỏ đâu. 2 vẫn là 2 8
vẫn là 8.
Có bỏ đâu. Tôi phải bắt hai ký tự. V bắt
tám đúng không? Chỗ này là bắt đúng hai
ký tự. Chỗ này là bắt tám ký tự trở lên.
Hai cái nó không bỏ nhau đâu.
Tại vì sao? Vì sao mình để 8? Tại vì số
điện thoại nó có tố hiệu là 10 số đúng
không? Thì ông ông trước bắt 2 rồi thì
ông sau bắt 8 trở lên thôi đúng không?
Số điện thoại Việt Nam bây giờ có thể có
là 10 số với 11 số đúng không? Có phải
là 10 với 11 bé nhất là 10 trừ bớt đi 2
rồi nó còn 8 đúng không? Hai này nó đều
bắt cả hai số nó vẫn bắt đúng không?
Khoảng trắng có thể có có thể không đúng
không? Bắt tiếp tám ký tự trở lên. Xong
rồi. Được chưa?
Rồi
có bắt nào câu hỏi gì không? Tất nhiên
đây là trường hợp mà mình những cái ví
dụ đơn giản thôi. Đây số điện thoại nó
sẽ có nhiều ví dụ khác các bạn sẽ phải
định nhãn nó phức tạp hơn. Đây nó là
trường hợp nó đ đơn giản thôi đúng
không? Đây nó có cả số ngoặc rồi nó có
dấu trừ th rất nhiều số khác rất nhiều
ký tự khác nữa đúng không? Nhiệm vụ
chúng ta làm sao chúng ta định nhá những
cái pattern làm sao để nó có thể nó
cover được tất cả những trường hợp nó có
thể xảy ra đúng không? Đấy là cái khó.
Tương tự các bạn có thể làm việc các bạn
có thể chiết suất email các thứ đúng
không? Thì như cái trường hợp chúng ta
đang làm, chúng ta muốn bắt xem là liệu
hai kên tự cuối nó có phải là cái mã của
cái bang không ấy. Nó cũng tương tự như
vậy thôi. Ví dụ nhá, ví dụ bạn thấy là
ví dụ chúng ta nó là ờ đây đây từ cái
rượu của chúng ta nhá. Đây
bộ đây nhá.
Mở thử nhá. Xem một cái vang trông như
thế nào. Đây
đây nhá. Austin TX nhá. Đúng không?
Austin ph nhá. Ví dụ nhá.
Đúng không? Thì bây giờ chúng ta phải
định nghĩa xem là làm sao để tôi bắt
được tôi phét điện được xem là liệu đây
có phải cái mã bang hay không đúng
không? Thì vừa có bạn bảo là gì? Dựa
theo cái quy tắc là gì? Là dấu phẩy này,
khoảng trắng này, hai cái tự chữ này
đúng không? Đấy, hai cái từ này nó phải
viết hòa đúng không? Thì rất là dễ thôi.
Nào, đầu tiên là dấu phẩy đúng không?
Dấu phẩy một dấu phẩy được chưa? Khoảng
trắng một khoảng trắng được chưa? Hai ký
tự chữ
A đến Z này phải viết hoa được chưa? Nó
phải có đúng hai đúng hai ký tự này.
Muốn chắc cú nữa thì tôi sẽ thêm một cái
ký tự kết thúc. Ký tự kết thúc như này
đây. Kết thúc này. Cái dấu cái dấu mũ
thì là bắt đầu của string đô la thì kết
thúc. Nếu chúng ta thêm ký tự kết thúc
có nghĩa là gì? Tức là tôi chỉ tìm nếu
mà nó là cái chuỗi cuối của một cái câu
thôi, của một cái text thôi. Được chưa?
Kết thúc tôi cho ch dấu đô la này. Được
chưa? Đấy. Kết thúc này. Đấy. Phẩy
khoảng trắng hai cái tự viết hoa này.
Được chưa? Tôi bắt như này.
Đây là cách đúng không? Sau khi mình bắt
được rồi mình sẽ chỉ lấy hai cái từ cuối
cùng thôi. Đúng không? Thì ví dụ chỗ nào
các bạn có cái USA nó sẽ không bắt được.
USA này nó không bắt được tại vì là nó
không đúng với cái cái khuôn mẫu này.
Được chưa?
Có bạn nào có thắc mắc gì ở chỗ này
không
nhá. Thế thời ngày xưa cái thời mà chưa
AI nó chưa có phát triển như bây giờ ấy.
Cái thời ngày xưa mà khi bọn mình phải
tiền sấy rượu với LM à với về với về với
về với với NLP ấ thì cái bước này phải
làm rất là nhiều. Nhưng mà bây giờ các
bạn thì bây giờ th vẫn phải làm nhưng mà
các bạn dùng AI các bạn các bạn cho nó
một vài cái ví ví ví ví ví ví ví dụ cái
đoạn tex mà các bạn cần phải lấy rồi các
bạn cần bảo là các bạn muốn lấy thông
tin gì là nó gen cho bạn ngay màý bây
giờ rất là dễ rồi nhá.
Bây giờ mình sẽ lấy luôn cái mẫu này để
mình để mình lọc đúng không? Bây giờ cái
nhiệm vụ mình là gì? Là bây giờ mình
muốn là bỏ bớt cái phần thành phố. Tôi
chỉ lấy mỗi cái mã bang thôi. Tôi chỉ
lấy đúng hai ký tự cuối nếu nó là ký tự
mã bang thật đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi
làm thế nào?
Thế thì bây giờ tôi sẽ phải định nghĩa
một cái hàm để nó lọc. Và cái hàm này
tôi sẽ áp dụng nó trên tất cả cho cho
nguyên cái cột location này. Được chưa?
Tôi sẽ thiết kế một cái hàm để nó lọc và
tôi sẽ ốp trên cái cột location này. Nếu
mà muốn dễ á, nếu mà muốn dễ th cái bài
này cũng không đến mức là phải dùng
expression thì bây gi mình sẽ thử từng
cách một nhá. Đầu tiên là cách dùng cách
dùng dễ này. Cách mà không cần phải
regular expression thì tôi nhẫn dễ thôi.
De này cái gì nhỉ? gọi là à
ờ không phải filter mà
ờ filter đi location đi nhá. Mình đ
nghĩa là cái location này nhá. Được
chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra kiểm tra
kiểm tra bốn ký tự cuối đúng không? Xem
là như thế nào. Ví dụ là if đúng không?
Ví dụ là đơn giản nhất là gì? If
location
-1 -2 -3 -4 đúng không? Ví dụ -4 bằng
đúng không? Nó là dấu phẩy được chưa?
N
location
-3 đúng không? Không cần phải lắng nhá
này đúng không? Dễ hơn. -4 đến -4 - 3 -2
đến -4 đến
-2 như này đúng không? Nó là dấu phẩy
cho khoảng trắng của cái này đúng không?
Nếu nó nếu nó như này đúng không? Hai
cái tự gần cuối nó như này đúng không?
Và
và hai ký tự cuối nó là viết hoa đúng
không? And
location
-2 này đúng không? Chấm này is
after đúng không nhỉ? After
mình không nhớ tên cái hàm nào.
Python
is
là gì nhở? À iser viết thường thôi. Viết
hoa này
is upper đúng không? Nếu hai ký tự gần
cuối là phẩy với khoảng trắng sau đó hai
ký tự cuối thật nó đều là ký tự viết hoa
cả thì tôi sẽ return hai ký tự cuối được
chưa?
Còn nếu không á, nếu không ấy thì tôi
return cả cái gốc ban đầu location này.
Được chưa? Đây là cái hàm mà tôi muốn là
tôi sẽ apply nó. Tôi sẽ áp dụng nó vào
trong cái
Tôi sẽ áp dụng nó vào trong cái cột
location của tôi. Đúng không? Tôi áp
dụng nó vào cột location của tôi. Đấy.
Thế bây giờ ở dưới này, ở dưới này sau
khi mà tôi lọc xong ấy đúng không? Data
đây đúng không? Tôi sẽ đọc nó này. Data
nhá. Đúng không? location này
bằng data location này chấm apply apply
cái hàm ở trên này cái hàm filter
location này được chưa các bạn nhìn thử
nhá nhìn thử mình chạy mình chạy thử này
xem khi mình apply này t gì mình apply
nguyên cái nguyên cái hàm này vào nguyên
cái cột location này đúng không nó sẽ áp
dụng cho từng cái ô của cột đấy một chạy
thử nhá Ah.
Ô sao lâu thế nhỉ? Đây
đây các bạn nhìn này. Đẹp rồi đây này.
Được chưa?
Đúng không? Ông nào mà không thỏa mãn
tôi trả về gốc ban đầu.
Được chưa?
Đẹp chưa? Trông có vẻ nó sẽ ít hơn rồi
đấy đúng không? Kiểu này là kiểu chưa
dùng regular expression đúng không các
bạn? Chỉ lọc dựa theo dấu hiệu thôi đúng
không? Nếu mà các bạn muốn lọc kiểu dựa
theo regular expression thì mình sẽ
modify một tí đi. Đấy mình cắt chỗ này
đi. Được chưa? Cắt chỗ này đi. Bây giờ
mình sẽ lấy cái mẫu ở ở đây này. Được
chưa?
Nó ở đây
nhá. Cái pattern chưa import này. Import
re được chưa? Cái button này mình phải
đổi đi. Cái button mình đây là phần lấy
số điện thoại đúng không? Mình sẽ phải
định nghĩa cái button của mình đây này.
Cái button mình vừa định nghĩa đây này.
Được chưa?
Đây đúng không? Tôi sẽ bắt như này đúng
không? Từ đây sẽ bắt cả cái chuỗi đấy.
Thế là thiếu
được chưa? Tôi sẽ apply nó vào cái
location tôi này. Được chưa? Nếu kết quả
ấy nó là một cái chuỗi mà nó không rỗng
đúng không? Kết quả của nó bao giờ? Kết
quả của cái thằng này bao giờ nó cũng là
một cái list kể các bạn định nghĩa cái
list ví dụ mình định nghĩa nó sai nhá.
Ví dụ mình định nghĩa là lên thành à 28
nhá đúng không? Nó sẽ nó sẽ rỗng này
đúng không? Nó vẫn là một cái list đúng
không? Thì nếu cái kết quả ấy nó trả về
một cái list mà nó rỗng ấy thì tôi sẽ
tức là gì? Tôi sẽ tôi sẽ trả về cái gốc
ban đầu này đúng không?
If
if lens của result này bằng 0. Thật ra
người ta sẽ là ghi là if not result là
xong. Nhưng mà thôi với cái này cũng
được chưa? Nếu l nó bằng 0 thì tôi sẽ
trả về location ban đầu. Còn không tôi
sẽ trả về location
này. Phần tử đầu tiên được chưa? Kết quả
nó cũng thế thôi đúng không? Kết quả hai
cái nó cũng như nhau thôi. Đây đúng
không? Nếu tôi không có kết quả nào thì
tôi sẽ trả về cái location gốc. Nếu có
tôi sẽ trả về cái phần tử đầu tiên. Mà
nó cũng chỉ có một phần tử thôi đúng
không? Một cái chỗ bạn nó cũng chỉ có
một cái ký tự mã ang thôi. À mình chỉ
lấy hai ký tự cuối thôi. Hai ký tự cuối
tôi sẽ trừ 2 chấm này. Được chưa? Tôi
chỉ lấy hai ký tự cuối thôi. Chạy thử
nhá. B đen chỗ này này. Chạy thử này.
Chạy thử nhá.
Đây
đây cũng y chả khác gì đúng không? Y chả
khác gì được chưa? Bây tôi chỉ lấy mã
bang thôi. Được chưa? Mã bang thôi. Thì
bây giờ có mã bang rồi tôi sẽ thử apply
on hot xem là bây giờ nó trông như nào
nó mặt mũi trông như nào. Được chưa? Vừa
nãy các bạn nhớ là chúng ta có khoảng
955 giá trị khác nhau đúng không? Thế
bây giờ tôi thử tôi bỏ đi cái thành phố
tôi chỉ giữ m m mã mã bang thôi. Tôi xem
còn bao nhiêu nhá.
Kiểu gì nó ít hơn đúng không? Kiểu gì nó
ít hơn đúng không?
Chờ một tí nhá. Chờ một tí nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này, nó còn có sáu mấy thôi
đúng không? Ít hơn cũng phải khoảng đến
mười mấy lần đấy nhở. Vậy là 955 đúng
không? Bây còn có 69 này đúng không? Bé
hơn hẳn rồi. Được chưa? Dùng có vẻ được
đấy. Đúng không? Được chưa? Tất nhiên
như mình nói rồi, ở đây chúng ta chúng
ta gom nó lại ấ thì nó cũng phải có cái
logic cái đấy chứ không phải là chúng ta
cứ thích là không phải chúng ta vì chúng
ta muốn giảm bớt nên là chúng ta bằng
cách chúng ta gom đúng không? Gom nó
phải có một cái logic gì đấy đúng không?
Logic mình đây là mình bảo là các cái
thành phố trung 3 thì yêu cầu nó xêm xêm
nhau đúng không? Thì mình gom nó vào
chưa?
Rồi thế thôi thì đây là về cột location
đúng không? Chúng ta có cái title rồi
location rồi đúng không?
Có nào câu hỏi gì không? Được hai cột
rồi. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Chúng ta đến với cột
thứ ba là cột à
job description đúng không? Description
đây.
Theo các bạn cái cột job description
chúng ta sẽ xử lý nó như nào? Bây giờ
chúng ta cũng phải số hóa nó đâ. Để
nguyên nó không chạy. Để nguyên thì
không đưa vào mô hình đúng không? Chúng
ta cũng phải xử lý nó xử lý như nào bây
giờ?
này
description này xử lý nào bây giờ
xử lý nào bây giờ
để nguyên này không đưa vào mô
để nguyên này chúng ta không đưa được
vào mô hình.
Tranging and gram. Trangking là gì?
Trang king ở đây có nghĩa là gì? Trang
king ở đây có nghĩa là gì?
Trang king ở đây có nghĩa là gì?
C lớp
tách text thành các đoạn nhỏ hơn.
Vì sao chúng ta lại phải tách text thành
cái đoạn nhỏ hơn? Tex nhỏ hơn nó có tác
dụng gì? Tex nhỏ hơn thì nó vẫn là tex.
May nó có hiểu đâu. Tex lớn nó vẫn là
tex, tex nhỏ nó vẫn là tex. May nó đâu
có hiểu.
Để nguyên máy nó không có hiểu.
Làm thế nào bây giờ?
Th nguyên này máy nó đâu có hiểu đâu
đúng không?
Nà nào bây giờ
mọi người? Có vẻ là mọi người cuối tuần
à mọi người sau buổi học là mọi người
không ôn bài đúng không? Xong mình cứ c
có có cảm giác là là những gì cuối tuần
trước mình dạy là là là
bay hết rồi thì phải m về người không
không không ôn bài à
thôi con này không xử lý nữa. À
mình hỏi các bạn khác đi. Lăng canh sao
có mỗi bạn
có mỗi bạn có mỗi bạn có mỗi bạn bạn
Hiếu thô này. Các bạn khác thì sao?
Mẹ lớp học một người à?
C description mình xử lý nào để nguyên
này máy nó không có hiểu đúng không? Máy
nó không hiểu text đúng không? Mình nói
các bạn rồi, máy nó không hiểu bàn, nó
chỉ hiểu số thôi. Các bạn để này các bạn
đưa vào mô hình nó chả có mô hình nào nó
hiểu được cái chỗ này cả đúng không?
Chúng ta phải xử lý nó, chúng phải số
hóa nó thế thì làm thế nào bây giờ?
Mọi người về mọi người không có ôn bài
lần trước vừa dậy rồi
trước vừa dạy xong mọi người chả chả ôn
bài thì càng ra tuần mới học học như mới
tinh thế này hôm qua chúng ta đã không
học rồi các bạn đã có coi như có thêm
một ngày để ôn bài mọi người chả chả chả
ôn gì cả
mà nó rất là dễ luôn các bạn ạ. Mình hỏi
các bạn thật ra câu trả lời mình đã đưa
cho các bạn luôn rồi. Mình đã cho các
bạn câu trả lời luôn rồi. Thế câu này
bây giờ xử lý nào? Trừ trừ bạn Hiếu ra
ché chẽ chả nhẽ chả nhẽ lớp mình có bao
nhiêu? Chả nhẽ 20 bạn còn lại không bạn
nào tìm ra cách nào để
back of words
các bạn khác nữa thì sao?
Ừ
các bạn nhìn này. Có thể mình nói hơi
nặng, có thể mình nói hơi nặng lời, có
thể mình nói hơi nặng lời nhưng não
chúng ta phải dùng để suy luận, để suy
nghĩ chứ không phải để đấy để trưng. Các
bạn cứ thử nghĩ mà xem. Các bạn cứ thử
nghĩ mà xem.
Cái cột title
nó lù lù một đống ở đây
đúng không? Cột title vừa nãy chúng ta
vừa mới nói về nó xong. Cuối buổi trước
nó nói về nó xong. Buổi này đầu buổi
cũng vừa nói về nó xong. Nó lù lù một
đống trước mắt các bạn.
Thế cái cột thay thuộc với cột discent
nó khác gì nhau. Nó đều là tex, nó đều
là văn xuôi. Thế thì cái cơ bản nhất các
bạn có thể nghĩ ra là gì? Là cột title
chúng ta làm như thế nào? Thì cột
description chúng làm y chang nó có khác
gì đâu. Khổ quá.
Các bạn thấy có đúng không? Thì có đúng
là các bạn có đúng là não là phải dùng
để nghĩ có đúng không? Thế bây các bạn
cứ chỉ xem b cái cột title người ta làm
như thế nào. Bây giờ các bạn bê nguyên
nó vào cột description là các bạn đã có
một cách rồi đúng không? Chưa nói có
hiệu quả hay không nhưng mà ít nhất nó
là một cách các bạn có thể thử được đúng
không? O2 đúng không? Kiến thức buổi
trước thì đã học rồi. Buổi này thì đã có
một cái ví dụ trước mắt rồi. Bây giờ chỉ
việc ốp nguyên ra thôi mà cả lớp từng
đấy ra mình có thể tìm ra được. Các bạn
đây nó có nó có phi lý không? Các bạn có
phải là lớp 1 lớp hai đâu? Toàn người
lớn cả rồi đúng không? Ví dụ thì ngay lù
trước mắt đây mình mở cho các bạn dữ
liệu để cho các bạn nhìn thấy không?
Title và discent nó chả khác gì nhau về
mặt bản chất cả đúng không? Thì có nghĩa
là gì? Có nghĩa là ông kia các bạn dùng
thử TF IDS thì ông này tôi cũng dùng thử
thôi đúng không? Đây ví dụ code ngay đây
rồi đúng không? Hai cái nó chả khác gì
nhau cả đúng không các bạn? Thế bây giờ
các bạn bảo bây giờ sau các bạn đi các
bạn đi làm chẳng nhẽ bây giờ lúc nào
cũng phải có một supervisor hay là chạy
đế lúc nào chúng ta không có AI chúng ta
chịu chết rồi đúng không? Chúng ta cũng
phải có cái suy luận m nó có khó cái gì
đâu các bạn ơi. Trời ơi là rời đúng
không? bảo bạn tính toán đã đành nên nó
có cái gì đâu. Khổ quá các bạn cứ bảo là
mình cũng phải muốn khó tính đâu nhưng
mà nó đơn giản quá cơ. Các bạn mà là
thằng Thắng nhà mình, các bạn mà là em
ruột của mình thì mình sẽ không nói nhẹ
nhàng như này đâu. Mình sẽ nói kiểu khác
cơ. Chẳng qua là các bạn là các bạn là
học viên của mình, các bạn cũng đóng
tiền cho mình và mình cũng không thể nào
mình quát các bạn quá mức được. Nhưng mà
rõ ràng là nó có khó gì đâu. Nó hiện lù
lù trước mặt mà. Trời ơi là rồi đúng
không? Thì cột kia làm nào? Cột này tôi
làm y chang là tôi đã có một cách rồi
đúng không? Chưa biết nó có hiệu quả nó
có tốt hay không nhưng mà nó là một cách
đã nó đúng không? Có gì đâu. Giời ơi là
rời
bảo hỏi cái gì cao siêu thế này không nó
lù lù đây mà buổi chữa học rồi mà đúng
không? Thế bây giờ mình chạy thử nhá mẹ
thử này. Đúng không? Đầu tiên mình vẫn
dùng tất cả mọi thứ mặc định đúng không?
Mặc định tôi không có biến cái gì tôi
dùng mặc định đây TFDF này đúng không? Ờ
tôi dùng này thì tôi dùng 11 nhá. Đúng
không? Các thứ mọi thứ mặc định cả đúng
không? Modify tí tính sao đúng cứ mặc
định đi trước chạy thử nhá chạy thử này
chạy thử này
nó sẽ hơi lâu tại vì cái cột này tex nó
rất là dài. Cột này chúng ta sẽ phải xác
nhận xác định là gì? Là là cái số
feature nó sẽ nhiều hơn rất là nhiều so
với c title đúng không? Nhiều hơn là bao
nhiêu? Để chạy thử đưa
hiện tại chúng ta vẫn chỉ dùng unigram
thôi đúng không? Mặc định chúng ta dùng
unigram cạnh như này. Số hàng thì vẫn
thế không có gì đặc biệt cả nhưng mà số
cột số cột là 67.28. 1280 đúng không? Nó
nhiều hơn rất nhiều so với cái cột
title. Cái cột title vảng 3000 thôi đúng
không? Title có khoảng 3000 đây. Nó có
từng này rồi. Đúng chưa? Thế và đây đây
là mới chỉ có unigram thôi. Được chưa?
Mình sẽ copy paste nhá.
Đây mới chỉ là
đây mới chỉ là uni thôi. Được chưa? Có
khoảng như này đúng không? Số hàng thì
không gì đặc biệt nhưng mà số cột chúng
ta sẽ có 67.280
từ đúng không? 672 67.284 trong cái từ
điểm của chúng ta được chưa? Thế
với cái cột title thì chúng ta dùng mặc
định này thì không có vấn đề gì nhưng mà
với cái cột với cái cột description
chúng ta hãy nhìn một chút này. Với cột
description ấy thì cái cột thay đổi nó
ngắn cái cột thay đổi nó ngắn nên là các
bạn dùng unigram là ok. Nhưng mà với
những cái cột thông tin nó dài như là
cái cột description này ấ chúng ta sẽ
muốn là chúng ta sẽ có thông tin về cả
cái thứ tự nữa đúng không? Thứ tự các
cái từ tờ đứng trước tờ đứng sau đúng
không? Thế thì nếu mà có mỗi unigram thì
có vẻ nó hơi ít. Chúng ta sẽ thử. Chúng
ta sẽ dùng cả thêm cả backam nữa. Mặc
định cái rin này ấy là nó sẽ là nó sẽ
chỉ dùng unii thôi. Min là 1, max là 1
mà. Thế tôi dùng tôi muốn dùng cả thì
tôi sẽ dùng 12 đúng không? Còn nếu mà
chỉ by thì là 22. Nhưng mà thường người
ta sẽ không bao giờ người ta dùng chỉ
một cái loại như vậy cả. Chúng ta thường
sẽ dùng cái range từ từ minimum là 1 cho
đến 2 hoặc là 3 hoặc 4 hoặc 5. Thông
thường các cái mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn này
người ta dùng maximum là 5 nhưng mà với
các mô hình ngôn ngữ lớn ấy thì người ta
sẽ không chia thành thành từ mà chia
thành token. Token thì nó có thể là nó
chỉ là một phần của một từ thôi. Được
chưa? Thế nhưng mà ở đây chúng ta sẽ
dùng chủ yếu là đơn vị là các cái từ
riêng lẻ đúng không? Thì ví dụ m rame
mình sẽ đổi này thành 12
nhá. Ừ. Ram
r nhá. bằng
1 2 như này được chưa? Lúc trước tôi chỉ
có uni thôi mà tôi vẫn còn chưa lọc
stopw nhá. Stop word thì lọc một chút
cũng được. Stop word thì lọc trong se ấy
nó chỉ có một cái bộ stopw của tiếng Anh
thôi. Các bạn dùng các bạn chỉ có một
option thôi. Đây ví dụ mình dùng nhá. Ví
dụ đây mình vẫn chưa dùng cái đây nhá.
Mình dùng stopw này. Stop word này bằng
English nhá. Một là các bạn truyền vào
như này. Hai là các bạn định nghĩa sẵn
là cái list này nó bao gồm cái scop nàyú
các bạn định nghĩa này đúng không? I này
đúng không?
này, we này đúng không? Đây ví dụ các
bạn định nghĩa như vậy thì một cái list
này các bạn có thể dùng NLTK để các bạn
lấy ra một cái list stopw này hoặc các
bạn dùng cái list mà nó có sẵn. List nó
có sẵn thì như mình nói chữ thì SER nó
là một thư viện mạnh về machining chứ nó
không mạnh về NLP. Nó có những cái hàm
phục vụ cho NLP nhưng mà đấy không phải
thấy mạnh của nó. Được chưa? Mình dùng
in này. Được chưa? In này muốn biết nó
có stop trông như nào thì các bạn nhìn
vào đây stopw nhá. Mình sẽ lấy cái stopw
này.
Stop ở đâu ấ nhỉ?
ST
word
đây nó có cái in stockw này. Đấy các cái
từ in stopw đây. Danh sách của nó nó lấy
từ cái bộ đây lấy từ cái bộ này này. Đấy
đây the original list này. Được chưa?
Xem thử có cái gì.
Cái stopw này thấy chưa? Đấy stopw của
người ta này. Chắc khoảng mấy mấy trăm
từ chưa? Chúng ta ở đây chúng ta ốp
stopw vào chắc là nó sẽ giản được bớt
một chút xíu đúng không? Chạy thử nhá.
Mình vẫn chạy lại vẫn stopw này đúng
không? Vẫn dùng là Unigram nhá. Unigram
thêm một cái chạy thử xem được bao nhiêu
nhá. Chắc nó sẽ giảm bớt một một chút.
Unigram cộng với
stopw này
trong cột không phải máy quen lỗi đâu.
Nó có những cái cái kự không phải
unicode mình sẽ phải lọc cả nó nữa. Bình
thường là mình sẽ phải lọc cả nó nữa nhá
các bạn. Bạn nhìn này,
các bạn nhìn thấy đây nhá. Cái cái mà
cái mà bạn đã hỏi nhá. Tức như này trong
cái a
trong có description nhá. Tức là nó là
cái kết quả của việc chúng ta lấy dữ
liệu từ từ web về. Đấy. Đây như thế này
đây nhá. Nó có những cái ký tự ví dụ như
là đây này. Ký tự này đúng không? Đấy.
Ký tự kiểu kiểu này đây các bạn nh chữ ớ
ớ này. Đấy những ký tự là đánh nhẽ bình
thường chúng ta sẽ phải lọc. Đấy, bây
giờ chúng ta làm này mà bây giờ chúng ta
phải lọc nó là những cái nó là những cái
ký ký tự mà không phải ký tự unicode nên
là khi mà lấy rượu về nó bị như này.
Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn tiếp nhìn nhá. Nhìn này. Khi
mà khi mà khi mà mình lọc stock word ấ
chản được một chút đây. 67.280 đây còn
66.94. Được chưa? Đây là mình chỉ có
unigram thôi. Bây giờ mình sẽ bắt đầu
mình cho thêm cả nữa.
Range nhá. bằng 1 2 như này. Được chưa?
Chạy thử này. Chạy thử này. Được chưa?
Xem vi nó sẽ có bao nhiêu nhá.
Chờ một tí các bạn nhá. Chạy nó hơi l
chút nhá.
unigram và byam được chưa? Các bạn nhìn
này, khi mình kết hợp với cả diagram,
các bạn thấy không? Số lượng nó lên đến
từng này đúng không? Unigram cộng với
đúng không? Lênn từng này
hơi khó hiểu nhỉ các bạn. Nhìn này, cái
hôm mà cái hôm mà chúng ta học về
ấy đúng không các bạn? Nhìn này, ví dụ
đây nhá. Chúng ta có cái input đầu vào
là cái từ này this is big data AI book.
Được chưa? Nếu chúng ta tách là unigram
chúng ta sẽ có 6 token. Chúng ta tch là
nó có 5 token. Tức là tức là đáng nhẽ là
cái số lượng token của Unigram với
Bogram ấy nó không có lệch nhau quá
nhiều đúng không? 1 ông 6 5 xêm xêm nhau
đúng không? xem xem nhau thế nhưng mà
mình không biết là vì sao ở đây khi mình
chạy thử dùng mỗi unigram thôi thì có
gần 6 7000 token nhưng bây giờ dùng cả
bam lại lên đến từng này nó gấp đến mười
mấy lần vì sao lại như thế các bạn nhỉ
nhìn có vẻ vô lý quá nhỉ vì sao lại như
vậy
vì sao lại như vậy
Vì sao mỗi unigram tôi có 67.000 mà bây
giờ thêm cả nữa thì tôi lại cao đến từng
này?
Vì sao
mình muốn các bạn khác nữa tính lập
table trừ hiếu ra trừ hiếu ra các bạn
khác đi. Có bạn nào có thể giải thích
mình là trừ hiếu ra có giải thích mình
là vì sao? Vì sao tôi lấy mỗi uni thôi
thì tôi có 67.000 Nhìn mà tôi có cả bam
tôi có tôi lại có đến hơn gấp 10 lần này
trong khi đ xong slide tôi học này đúng
không? Slide tôi học đây đúng không? D
lượng unigram về bi nó cũng xêm xêm nhau
mà sau đây sau đây nó lại khác biệt này
vì sao mà thêm cả background lại nhiều
lần thế này
có nào giải thích được
Có bạn giải thích được không? Vì sao? Vì
sao tôi chỉ có unigram thì tôi có 67.000
Nhìn mà tôi thêm 3 g lại đến hơn gấp 10
lần này.
Tách từng phần tử rồi gộp tất cả khả
năng. Tức là sao? Mình vẫn chưa hiểu.
Đây các bạn nhớ không? Đây này. Số lượng
unigram về 3 nó sẽ nó phải xêm xêm với
nhau chứ đúng không? Unigram nó còn lớn
hơn một tí.
Đây uni với 3 gram đây. Đây ví dụ đây
đúng không? Ví dụ đây. Speak dat book
đúng không? Unigram là bao gồm các cái
từ riêng lẻ còn là bao gồm hai từ liên
tiếp nhau đúng không? Biogram là bao gồm
hai từ liên tiếp nhau. Thì theo mình
thấy cái ví dụ ở đây đúng không? Số
lượng unigram với biogram nó xấp xỉ nhau
đúng không? Thậm chí là unin nó còn
nhiều hơn. Thì theo mình hiểu thì nếu mà
tôi có tôi dùng unigram tôi có bao nhiêu
thì tôi thêm tôi có khoảng gấp đôi đúng
không? Cộng hai ông lại gấp gấp đôi lúc
ban đầu đúng không?
Không phải tổ hợp nó chỉ có hai từ liên
tiếp nhau thôi các bạn nhìn này. 3 chỉ
có hai từ liên tiếp nhau thôi. Z is là
một inspect là được. Các bạn không được
gộp zit với cả book đâu đúng không?
Zitbook không gộp được. Nó chỉ bao gồm
hai từ liên tiếp nhau thôi chứ nó không
phải nó không đánh nhau tổ hợp đâu.
Không không có nhảy cóc đâu. Chỉ hai từ
liên tiếp nhau.
Triagram cũng thế bao gồm ba từ liên
tiếp nhau chứ không có chuyện nhảy góc
đâu.
Làm sao
ở đây tôi thấy là đúng không? Số lượng
uni và nó xêm xêm nhau thì đáng nhẽ nếu
mà chỉ có unigram nó có 67.000 thì thêm
thì nó lên khoảng 100 a 130.000 thì là
ok đúng không? Nhưng mà sau đây nó lên
đến 840 45.000 này
có ai giải thích được không?
Trừ bạn Hiếu ra có bạn nào giải thích
được lý do là vì sao?
Vì sao?
Vì sao tôi thêm mỗi cái diagram thôi mà
số lượng token tôi lại vọt lên như này
gấp hơn 10 lần này. Mười mấy lần đúng
không? Vô lý nhở. Nó phải xêm xêm nhau
chứ đúng không?
Thậm chí là số unigram đáng nhẽ nó phải
nhiều hơn. Tức là cộng thêm nó chỉ gấp
gần gấp đôi thôi. Thế mà đây nó gấp đến
mười mấy lần này. Vô lý nhỉ?
Các bạn giải thích được vì sao không?
Tại vì
có phải số
không có nhiều combination khác nhau vô
lý. Nhiều combination khác nhau là rất
vô lý. Làm sao mà nhiều được các bạn
nhìn đây đúng không? Nó chỉ có chỉ có
năm tổ hợp thôi mà đúng không? Nếu là
các bạn hiểu câu hỏi của mình không? Nếu
là unigram ấy các bạn có sáu tần đúng
không? Z là 1, is là 1, big là 1, data
là 1, A là 1 và book là 1. Các bạn có
sáu token đúng không? Bagram các bạn có
bói ra nó cũng chỉ có được 5 thôi đúng
không? Nhiều là nhiều ở đâu đúng không?
Làm sao mà nhiều được? This is là 1, is
big là 2, big data là 3, data a là 4, a
book là 5. Nhiều đâu mà nhiều, lấy đâu
ra mà nhiều bây giờ đúng không? Lấy đâu
ra mà nhiều đúng không?
Có đây đúng không? Đây ví dụ trước mặt
đây. Các bạn nhìn về slide này đúng
không? Làm sao mà nhiều được đúng không?
Nó còn thậm chí nó còn ít hơn.
Do lấy cả tốc của
Ừ ừ đây. Ừ thì đây lấy cả hai đây. Thì ý
câu hỏi của mình
cái câu hỏi của mình câu hỏi của mình ấy
là gì? Là khi mà tôi chỉ lấy unigram thì
tôi có khoảng 67.000 có đúng không?
Unigram có khoảng 67.000 có đúng không?
Thế bây giờ có phải ở đây tôi thấy là
gì? Số lượng unigram với cả backgram nó
cũng xêm xêm nhau. Thậm chí là uni còn
nhiều hơn đúng không? Thì đáng nhẽ nếu
kết hợp cả unni với buy ấy thì nó chỉ có
khoảng gấp đôi token thôi. T đây là
67.000 gấp đôi lên nó chỉ khoảng là tră
ba mấy nghìn thôi đúng không? Nhưng mà
đây nó lại đến gấp hơn chục lần thế này
thì mình hỏi lý do là vì sao chứ ai mà
chả biết là kết hợp cả univerb đúng
không? Đây mình ghi rõ đây còn rồi còn
gì nữa
đúng không? cùng nội dung những cách
miêu tả công việc khác nhau.
Cùng nội dung như cách miêu cùng một nội
dung nhưng cách miêu tả công việc giữa
các hàng khác nhau thì thì liên quan gì?
cùng một nội dung những cách miêu tả
công việc giữa hai hàm khác nhau thì
liên quan gì đến việc là khi tôi có ba
nó nhiều này
cả unigram và bam đều lấy unic các bạn
nhá.
Ở đây đây cũng là unic. Đây cũng là
unic. Tất cả đều là đều là unic cả đúng
không? Đều là tôi sẽ không lấy trùng lặp
đúng không? Đây là đây đều là không lấy
trung lập.
Unigram tôi cũng không lấy trung lập mà
3 tôi cũng không lấy trung lặp đúng
không? Cái xất hiện nhiều nó cũng chỉ
tính là 1 thôi đúng không? Tất cả đều là
không lấy trùng lặp.
Bạn nào giải thích được
có một cái bình luận các bạn. Mình miss
có phải số tổ hợp hai từ liên tiếp khác
nhau sẽ nhiều hơn số đơn?
Có phải
có phải số tổ hợp hai từ liên kết thấp
khác nhau sẽ nhiều hơn số đơn trùng?
Bạn à bạn Vũ Quốc Phong có thể nói ờ nói
nói cụ thể hơn một tí được không? Mình
mình vẫn chưa hiểu lắm. Vũ quốc Phong có
phải số tổ hợp hai từ liên tiếp khác
nhau sẽ nhiều hơn số đơn
khác nhau trùng lặp tức là như nào nhỉ?
Có phải số tổ hợp hai từ liên tiếp khác
nhau sẽ nhiều? Mình mình mình vẫn mình
vẫn chưa hiểu lắm. Có phải số tổ hợp hai
từ liên tiếp khác nhau sẽ
nhiều hơn số đơn trùng lặp?
Mình vẫn chưa hiểu lắm. Đúng mình chưa
hiểu lắm.
Quá giấy được không
bạn? Hiếu giải hí được không?
Hiếu dậy được không? Vì sao? Vì sao khi
mà tôi lấy mỗi uni thôi tôi có từng này
mà tôi lấy cả bam tôi có từng này?
À cái cái góc diện của em là em đang
thấy ví dụ như khác nhau giữa hai cái
sample á anh. Ví dụ ví dụ
ví dụ như là bây giờ nó sẽ có ví dụ nó
lấy nó lấy backagram là như là this is
is big đi.
>> Thì thì nếu mà nếu mà ở dưới á mà nó có
lặp lại đi thì nó sẽ không có bị nhanh
lên. Mà bây giờ giả sử một cái sample
khác mà nó có là dis are thì đó là nó
những cái nó không tồn tại nó sẽ trồng
theo mấy cái cột vào thì khi đó nó chồng
theo nhiều cột vào thì sẽ dẫn tới cái
số lượng feature nó tăng lên là dựa trên
các cái unit feature của từng cái
unigram từng cái background của nó.
>> Ừ.
Ok rồi thôi mình tổng hợp lại. Ok. Ok.
Rất cảm ơn. Mình nghĩ là cũng có vẻ có
có ý hiểu đúng nhưng mà thôi là để mình
giải thích lại nhá. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
kết hợp một từ với một từ khác có nghĩa
khác nhau. Tức là sao? Mình vẫn các bạn
nhìn nhá. Vì sao mà khi mà tôi chỉ có
unigram thôi thì tôi có ít mà khi mà tôi
có thêm background tôi lại có nhiều đến
như vậy. Trong khi rõ ràng ở đây là số
lượng hàm này nó xêm xêm nhau. Thì tại
vì như thế này, tại vì những gì mà các
bạn đang nhìn thấy trên ảnh này ấy, đây
chỉ là một một đoạn text, một sample
thôi. Các bạn hiểu này, khi các bạn tách
bằng unigram ấy thì khả năng những cái
unigram này xuất hiện đi xuất hiện lại
nó sẽ nhiều đúng không? Cái từ zist này
ấy, trong document nào nó cũng có đúng
không? Cái từ this với từ is này ấy
nhưng cái từ này nó ngắn nên cái khả
năng nó xuất hiện lại trong document
khác nó rất là nó rất là cao đúng không?
Và khi nó xuất hiện lại ấy thì tôi vẫn
chỉ đếm nó là một lần thôi đúng không?
Thì cái khi mà unigram ấy thì cái khả
năng cái tầ này xuất hiện đi xuất hiện
lại trong nhiều document khác thì nó sẽ
rất là nhiều. Khi xuất hiện lại nhiều
như vậy tôi chỉ đếm một lần. Còn diagram
là những cái từ hai từ đi kèm với nhau
này ấy thì cái khả năng chúng nó xuất
hiện lại trong document khác nó sẽ ít
hơn. Và khi nó xuất hiện ít hơn thì số
lượng số lượng những cái từ liên tiếp
nhau ta sẽ nhiều hơn đúng không? Trong
cái document khác có thể nó cũng có cái
từ z nó cũng có cái từ y nó cũng có cái
từ big nhưng mà nó sẽ không đi cùng nhau
theo thứ tự này. Nó sẽ đi cùng với nó sẽ
kết hợp với ông khác đúng không? Nên là
cái số n này ấy nó cứ nó cứ càng lớn thì
cái khả năng nó lặp lại, khả năng nó
xuất hiện lại nó càng ít đi. Thế nên là
khi ở đây là tôi đang đếm trên một
document thì đúng là số lượng của uni,
byram nó xêm xê nhau. Nhưng khi tôi có
1000, 100.000 hay là 1 triệu document ấy
đúng không? Thì rõ ràng là cái unigram
ấy nó sẽ số lượng nó sẽ xuất hiện nó ít
thôi. Tại vì là nó là b lại mà tôi cái
từ zit này xuất hiện 100 lần thì nó cũng
chỉ là một từ zit, nó chỉ đến một lần
thôi. Nhưng mà cái từ zit ở trong cái
diagram nhá. Ông đây là zit e chỗ kia nó
lại là zit cái gì đây? Zitbook, zit
band, zit car, zit cat, zit dog đúng
không? Nó sẽ kết luận từ khác nó sẽ tạo
ra nhiều tổ hợp hơn đúng không? Nên là
khi mà cái sự cái document tôi nó nhiều
ấy thì cái số lượng các cái diagram nó
được tạo ra nó sẽ nhiều hơn rất là nhiều
so với unigram. Và tất nhiên tương tự
như vậy với triagram nó còn nhiều nữa. N
càng nhiều, en nó càng lớn ý thì số
lượng những cái token nó được tạo ra sẽ
càng nhiều. Thế nên ở đây chúng ta thấy
là gì? Chúng ta thấy là khi mà chúng ta
dùng đấy để ra nhiều thế này đúng không?
Trong cái chỗ này ấy đúng không? Ví dụ
chúng ta có một cái từ là beautiful. Từ
beautiful nó xuất hiện rất nhần nhưng mà
ở đây mỗi một mỗi cái token đây nó xuất
hiện rất là ít thôi. Tại vì là n nó càng
lớn thì nó càng khó lắp lại mà đúng
không? Thế nên là không phải là số lượng
unigram với bogram nó xếp xếp nhau đâu
mà số lượng bygam nó sẽ nhiều hơn rất là
nhiều và nó sẽ càng nhiều hơn khi mà số
lượng document chúng ta xử lý nó càng
nhiều đúng không? Chúng ta xử lý một
document thì số lượng unigram với nó xêm
xêm nhau nhưng chúng ta xử lý rất rất
nhiều document thì cái khoảng cách càng
xa ra. Được chưa?
Chúng ta mà dùng trio nó còn nhiều nữa.
Được chưa? Đấy là lý do vì sao mà tôi
chỉ thêm mỗi n và tăng lên bằng 2 thôi
thì tăng lên nhiều thế này. Được chưa?
Khi mà các bạn dùng n cao thì cái ưu
điểm là các bạn sẽ có cả thông tin mà
thứ tự nhưng mà nhược điểm là nó sẽ
khiến cho cái vocabi bạn nó sẽ phình to
ra. Phình to ra lại tiêu tố nhiều tài
nguyên hơn đúng không? Tiêu tố nhiều hơn
xử lý mất thời gian hơn. Đúng chưa? Tốt
hơn hay không thì còn phải xét đã. Nhưng
mà trước mắt là chúng ta thấy nó tốn
thành nguyên hơn cái đã đúng không?
Theo chúng ta xử lý được ba cột rồi đúng
không? Cột title chúng ta dùng TF IDF.
Cột location chúng ta dùng hot. Cột
cột cột cột job description chúng ta lại
dùng tiếp IDF tiếp đúng không?
Máy nó không biết đâu nhá.
Xét số từ 1 2 thì làm sao để máy biết
khi nào nên dùng. Máy nó không biết.
Chúng ta là người chúng ta phải chúng ta
phải thiết lập. Chúng ta sẽ là người
chúng ta phải chỉ ra là dùng bao nhiêu
máy nó không biết đâu. Tất nhiên các bạn
có thể dùng green search để các bạn xem
là đâu là cái bộ tối ưu đúng không?
Green search các bạn 112 13 đúng không?
Bao giờ ta thường ta sẽ lấy một cái mức
từ min đến max chứ người ta sẽ không có
chuyện là người ta chỉ lấy diagram hay
là lấy gram đâu đúng không? 11213 dùng
green search xem cái nào tốt nhất đó máy
nó không biết mình là phải tự chỉ ra
rồi các bạn có câu hỏi gì không
đây nhá được chưa được ba cột rồi thế
bây giờ chúng ta nghỉ dài đây là 5 phút
nhá xong chúng ta học tiếp nhá chúng ta
còn hai cột nữa xong rồi chúng ta sẽ
ghép vào với nhau là xong được chưa xong
rồi chúng ta sẽ khi chúng ta chuyên xong
rồi chúng ta sẽ nói việc cho tối ưu đúng
không chuyên được chạy được đã rồi cho
tối ưu xem làm sao cho nó tốt hơn nhá.
Bạn nào mà muốn hỏi gì các bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi nhá.
Ok tiếp các bạn nhá. Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Rồi các bạn chúng ta xử lý được ba cột
rồi đúng không? Chúng ta còn hai cột nữa
vẫn phải xử lý tiếp đúng không? Xử lý
xong hết đã nhá. Nào cột tiếp theo nào.
Tiếp theo là cột function đúng không?
Cột function r cột industry được chưa?
Function này
một tí nhá.
Nào, function nào
các bạn cột function theo các bạn chúng
ta xử lý bằng cách nào bây giờ? Nhìn vào
đây các bạn thấy nào? Thôi
đây function theo các bạn mình xử lý ý
nào bây giờ?
Xử ý nào bây giờ các bạn?
Ừ lại onhot đúng không? Thử onhot trước
ít thì dùng không thì lại idf đúng
không? Unhot function nhá.
Function nào?
Đâu rồi? On not encoder đây. Enquader
đây nhá. Đúng không? Mình sẽ encoder ở
đây.
Function
nữa
thì nó yêu cầu phải là mảng hai chiều đi
vào onhot. Yêu cầu input phải là mảng
hai chiều. Trong khi vorizer trong TFF
nó chỉ yêu cầu mảng một chiều thôi nên
là onhot mình phải đóng hai dấu vào đây
cho nhìn nhá.
Trong vẻ ok các bạn nhở. Ít này đúng
không? 19 đấy đúng không? Xong rồi chưa?
Ừ ít mà đúng không? Ít trong có vẻ dùng
được đúng không? Chết rồi. Cái gì đây?
Còn cột industry. Còn cột industry.
Industry đâu rồi? Industry
chạy này nhá. Còn industry nữa.
Industry.
Cột industry.
Đây
các bạn thấy nào các bạn? Industry các
bạn thấy nào?
làm sao?
Có thể thử not trước đúng không? Thử bó
trước nếu mà nó nhiều quá thì mình dùng
tidsf đúng không? Thử nhá.
Industry này
đâu rồi?
Đây
chưa?
Industry nhá.
nó hơi nhiều nhỉ? Nhiều đúng không?
Th v dụ mà dùng TF IDF đi đúng không? Ví
dụ dùng TF IDF nhá. Được chưa?
Tizer này. Tất nhiên có khi nó còn tạo t
nhiều hơn nhưng mà tiếp IDF thì nó sẽ nó
sẽ đỡ thưa hơn nhá. Ví dụ Vectorizer
nhá.
Cô này có lẽ các bạn dùng cái nào được
on hot được là tiếp thì cũng ok.
On này sẽ coi cả một cái hàng đấy là một
giá trị trong khi TFDF này tách thành
từng từ riêng lề đúng không?
Thôi cứ dùng TF IDF cũng được nhá. Cái
này riêng cột này các bạn dùng cái nào?
Ok được chưa? Thế tóm lại là gì? Tóm lại
là bây giờ mình có năm cột đúng không?
Mình có năm cột và mình sẽ
mình có thể dùng so đây ví dụ đây các
bạn nhìn này. Đúng không? Ví dụ đây nhá.
Ví dụ là cột cột title các bạn dùng TF
IDF đúng không? Location dùng unhot.
Description lại dùng TF IDF. Function
lại one hot, industry lại dùng TF IDF
đúng không? Cái cột cơ level nó là cột
tit các bạn không cần phải số hóa đâu.
Không phải số hóa thành 234 đâu. Say cái
nó tự làm cho các bạn được chưa? Nó tự
làm cho các bạn thành các cái số rồi các
bạn không cần phải mã hóa cái cái level
này. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ các bạn nhìn
này. Bây giờ chúng ta có năm cột thế
này. Mỗi cột nó có các cái cách xử lý
khác nhau đúng không? Ông thì TF IDF,
ông thì one hot. Thế bây giờ ấy mình mà
muốn mình muốn thiết kế để làm sao mình
chỉ ra là gì? là cột title thì tôi dùng
TF IDF, cột location tôi dùng hot, cột
description tôi lại dùng TFIDF, cột
function tôi lại dùng hot. Ô mẹ dùng
TFDF. Bây giờ tôi muốn chỉ ra là tôi sẽ
áp dụng các cái phép biến đổi khác nhau
và các cột khác nhau thì tôi đã dùng cái
gì bây giờ? Xong sơ
dùng cái gì bây giờ?
Đó lại dùng colum transformer đúng
không? Pipeline để tôi gục. Pipeline là
dùng để thiết kế kiểu nối tiếp còn
column transformer thiết kế kiểu song
song đúng không? Một ông là nối tiếp là
ông này trước ông ông kia sau. Còn colum
transformer để song song. Song song tức
là gì? Năm cái này chạy đúng song song
nhau. Đúng thì mình sẽ dùng colum
transformer đúng không? Lại dùng giống
cái bài trước thôi. Lại dùng cái bài vi
question này. Được chưa? Chúng ta dùng
chúng ta dùng column transformer đây
này. Đây này. Đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ
chỉ ra là gì? Đã nhìn với cái bài trước
là mỗi một cái bước của chúng ta nó lại
là một cái pipeline nhưng mà cho trong
bài này chúng ta cũng không cần tại vì
là chúng ta đã xử lý những cái ô nó bị
khuyết rồi đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ dùng
luôn col transformer này. Được chưa? C
transformer thì đ import này đây được
chưa
import này đã chỉ ra là từng ông tôi xử
lý bằng cái gì đúng không tôi sẽ không
xử lý kiểu thủ công này nữa không thủ
công này nữa tôi sẽ gọi gì một cái gọi
là processor được chưa bằng colum
transformer này được chưa transformer
như này được chưa cái đầu tiên là gì của
title
title feature đúng không tôi sẽ dùng là
ids này đúng không tôi sẽ áp dụng lên
các Các bạn chú ý này, với cái TF IDF
ấy, chúng ta chỉ chúng ta bỏ cái dấu
chúng ta bỏ cái dấu list ra nhá. Tại vì
nó chỉ áp dụng lên một cái mảng một
chiều thôi. Bỏ cái list ra được chưa?
Title xong rồi này. Đúng không? À thứ
hai là thứ hai là à
location location cái đầu tiên nó thì nó
chỉ là cái cái tag thôi. Cái này các bạn
gọi gì cũng được mà các bạn gọi tên gì
gợi nhớ một chút. Còn cái cuối là các
bạn chỉ ra cái nó áp dụ như cái cột nào
cái này thì buộc phải đúng nhá. Ông cuối
thì buộc phải đúng còn ông đầu thì các
bạn muốn chọn gì cũng được. Vâ các bạn
bị tắt cũng được. Title title như này
cũng được đúng không? Title như này như
này được chưa? Location các bạn ghi là
log thôi cũng được không vấn đề. Ông
cuối mà ông cần đúng đúng không? One
hotquer như này. One hot
hoter
này được chưa? Đấy và sẽ áp dụng vào
cột. Cái này thì tôi lại one hot thì tôi
lại phải chỉ ra list này. Được chưa?
Location được chưa? Tất nhiên là tôi
mình cũng có thể kèm cái function vào
thôi. Mình sẽ viết mỗi cái một dòng cho
nó cho nó nhìn cho dễ. Được chưa này
nhá. Đúng không? Tiếp theo là cột job
description.
Description này
được chưa? Tôi dùng tiếp này tôi sẽ cho
ram
range bằng 1 đến 2. Được chưa?
Stopw
bằng
bao nhiêu?
Ví dụ như này nó stopw là nhỉ? Stop à
đây. Stop word gạch cái stopw đây bằng
nhá. Được chưa?
Rồi
function giống thì giống như là location
thôi. Mình viết mỗi ông một cái cho nó
từ minh. Mặc dù các bạn có thể gộp vào
với nhau được.
function vào đây.
Function này
đây đúng không? Industry cũng giống
title thôi.
Industry
à thường cái dòng này industry này. Được
chưa?
Industry
nó xong rồi. Thấy chưa? Đây là cái a
bước tiền xí chúng ta đúng không? Chúng
ta có năm cột, mỗi cột chúng ta sẽ có
cách xử lý khác nhau. Được chưa? Sau đó
mình lại à lại sau khi mình định nghĩa
xong mình sẽ nối nó vào cái với mô hình
thôi. Đây mô hình ra đây này. Đâu rồi?
Đây mô hình như thế này đúng không? Fly
như này.
Đây nhép vào đây. Tất nhiên chúng ta
phải đổi mô hình đi đúng không? Đây là
bài toán dành cho mô hình ạ. Đây đây là
bài toán phân loại rồi không phải bài
toán reaction nữa. Phải đổi nó đi đúng
không? Phải có import này.
Form lep
này nhá. Được chưa? Fine này được chưa?
Form c learn chí như là
import
classifier
classfier
được chưa? Classifier nhá. Ờ. Ờ đây được
chưa? Mình bước này xong mình sẽ bắt đầu
mình lại giống mình bước sau lại fit
thôi. Đây
mình gọi nó là model đi nhá. Moder đi.
Moder đi. Được chưa? Moder
chấm fit này. Exchange
trend được chưa? trên này ờ
exe nhá đúng không? Th ra bây giờ mình
mình muốn mình muốn xem là gộp năm ông
này lại thì có bao nhiêu feature đúng
không? Bây giờ mình mình đang muốn xem
là trước khi mình chạy mình huấn luyện
mình muốn xem là năm này gộp lại để có
bao nhiêu feature đúng không thì mình sẽ
chạy thử này chạy thử nhá ví dụ như là
output này đúng không
free service fish transform exchange này
đúng không đây mình chỉ cần xchange thôi
mình xem output shape bằng bao nhiêu nhá
green này output ch được chưa chạy thử
nhá gộp năm ông vào với nhau được chưa
chạy thử này
tất nhiên Trong năm này thì cái ông ở
giữa sẽ là ông tốn kém nhất đúng không?
Thử này
xem bao nhiêu feature nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này, tổng cộng bây giờ ấy
mình gộp ba ông lại với nhau thì có
tương thấy feature đúng không? Ờ tất
nhiên phần lớn nó thì đến từ cái ông
description đúng không? Đây mình ban đầu
nhá.
Migram cộng với by đúng không? Phần lớn
là lấy từ nó mình sẽ ghi vào đây đúng
không? Như này được chưa? Đấy là cái
bước chúng ta chúng ta chúng ta tiền xử
lý đúng không? Nhưng mà bây giờ mình cho
tắt đi đúng không? Bật qu trình huấn
luyện mô hình ở đây đ không?
N xong tất nhiên mình có thể mình đem nó
đi đem nó đi test thử test thử lại copy
từ cái bài trước thôi.
Đây đúng không? Cái đạn mà chúng ta fit
xong bắt đầu mình bắt đầu mình em dự
đoán này được chưa? Dự đoán đây chưa?
Ờ in cả cái con fusion magic cũng được
chưa?
Hit xong rồi nhá. Được chưa? Bỏ cái này
đi đúng không? Infure magic được chưa?
formar.
Được chưa? Chạy thử nhá. Chạy thử này.
Cái này thì in thêm xem là ông nào hay
nhầm ông nào. Ch mình xem cái phần
classification report xem kết quả như
nào nhá. Đổi đi, đổi vị trí đi. Mình cho
conversation m chích lên trên đi. Được
chưa? Chạy thử nhá.
Không, feature quá lớn nó không phải
feature quá lớn không phải lý do mà là
khi mà dữ liệu nó đơn giản mà mô hình nó
quá phức tạp nó dễ bị ô fiting. Dữ liệu
mà đơn giản trong khi mô hình nó lại quá
phức tạp sẽ bị ô fiting. Giống kiểu là
học vẹt ấy. Tức là gì? Bình thường tôi
học ví dụ học toán tôi học là tôi học
cách giải phả toán tổng quát nhưng mà
khi tôi học tôi lại học kiểu học cứ học
học nhớ học vẹt đấy. Thế tức là bây giờ
đề bài nó chỉ đổi đi một tí thì tôi
không làm được. Đấy thì đấy là fitting
feature phức tạp không phải lý do mà là
khi mà mô hình phức tạp nó mới là lý do
nhá.
Chạy thử nhá các bạn nhìn này. Chạy thử
nhá. Chạy thử nhá.
Nó sẽ hơi lâu các bạn nhá. Nó sẽ hơi lâu
nhá. Thì bản thân cái mô hình ta là nó
là một cái mô hình nó rất là lớn đúng
không? Mình hình này các bạn có 100 cây
ở bên trong là chạy nó rất là lâu. Chờ
một tí nhá. Chờ một tí nhá. Trong lúc
chờ chạy các bạn muốn hỏi gì bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Chờ nó một chút chắc bạn hết khoảng
1 2 phút đấy nhá.
Bạn nào các bạn muốn hỏi gì các bạn cứ
hỏi nhá.
H lâu một tí nhở.
Có chứ có chứ. T phải ch form
phải ch form nó mới hiểu được
hơi lâu nhỉ. Nhiều feature quá đúng
không? Nhiều phờ 800 8 gần 850.000 đúng
không? Rất nhiều
khi Fit X train vào mô hình rồi
không? Nó vẫn có thể thiếu chứ nó vẫn có
thể thiếu
nó vẫn có thể thiếu chuyện bình thường.
Khi mà nó thiếu như vậy thì coi như từ
đấy nó là không thôi.
Tập test á không phải các bạn ạ. Trong
cái
trong trong khi mà các bạn làm cái
pipeline này ấy là bên trong cái p này
nó bao gồm cả cái khi các bạn làm cái
pipeline này ấy thì trong cái test này
nó nó nó bao gồm cả cái bước mà chúng ta
transform ở trên rồi các bạn nhớ không?
Transform mình mình đâu có transform thủ
công đâu đúng không? Mình cũng đâu có
fit transform bộ train đâu đúng không?
Khi mà các bạn làm cái paper này rồi thì
nó bao gồm cả fit transform cho trin với
cả transform cho test. Rồi fit này có
nghĩa là nó sẽ fit transform còn prex
này là nó sẽ transform ở bên trong.
Các bạn nhìn này. Mình có một cái lỗi
này nhá. Mình có một cái lỗi này. Value
er này. F un cat in column này. Đây
bạn nào chí mình cái lỗi này. Vì sao mẹ
có cái lỗi này?
Vì sao lại có cái lỗi này?
Nhớ nhá. Khi chúng ta gọi fit này ấ là ở
bên trong là nó đã fit tr form phía trên
rồi. Còn khi chúng ta gọi cái prck này ở
trong nó có cái trang form cái test rồi.
Chúng ta không phải gọi thủ công nhá.
Nào các bạn.
Mình sợ có cái lỗi này. Ai thích mình
cái lỗi này từ đâu mà ra?
Từ đâu mà ra đây?
Nó từ cái dòng này nó từ cái dòng số 55
này. Trên thì không sao mà test lại lỗi
đúng không? Dòng 54 vẫn ok nhưng dòng 55
có vấn đề. Dòng 55 có vấn đề. Đây lý do
à đúng rồi. One hot coding bị thiếu một
số giá trị của xtest. Vì sao lại như
vậy? Sao lại có những giá trị này nằm
trong sao lại trong bộ test có mà bộ
trên lại không có?
Sao bộ test có mà bộ trên lại không có
các bạn? Vì sao? Đúng rồi. C của C
location đấy đúng không? Chứ của
location vì sao location nó có những cái
giá trị như là KCHU key hoặc là BCCB mà
bộ tren lại không có? Vì sao?
À thế mình lý do vì sao bộ test sao lại
có những cái sample này mà bộ trên lại
không có.
À đúng rồi. Tại vì số lượng sample có
những này nó ít quá nó chỉ có một hai
sample thôi mà chia chẳng may lại rơi
hết vào bộ test. Bộ trên nó không có
đúng không?
Nó ví dụ cái tuki nó chỉ có một sample
thôi. Cái mcb nó chỉ có một sample thôi.
Chẳng may khi chia thì lại chẳng may khi
chia thì nó lại rơi hết vào vào bộ test
rồi. Bộ trên chả có cái gì cả nên là nó
bị lỗi. Được chưa? Thì trường hợp này là
trường hợp có thể xảy ra mà đúng không?
Thế bây giờ khi nó xảy ra tôi phải fix
cho nó đúng không? One hot.
Nó có nhiều cách fix các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Nó sẽ có một cái là
handle unknown đúng không? Specify the
way unknown categories are handles
during transform đúng không? Transform
này nó xảy ra cho cả bộ truy và cả bộ
test. Tại vì trong bộ truyên là fit
transform thì nó cũng có transform. Bộ
test là nó transform thì nó cũng có
transform riêng đúng không các bạn?
Không cái lỗi này chứng minh là gì? Là
quá trình test nó có transform thật đúng
không? Bên trong cái prit này nó có
transform. Bên trong cái fit này nó cũng
có fit transform. Được chưa? Thế thế bây
giờ các bạn nhìn này, nó có một vài cách
giải quyết. Cách đầu tiên phổ biến nhất
là gì? Là cách mặc định là gì? Là erop
tức là gì? Gặp lỗi là nó bung ra lỗi.
Bung ra lỗi là chư các bạn khỏi chạy
luôn đúng không? Chạy là nó sẽ lỗi đỏ
lòm đấy. Đúng không? Cái thứ hai là cách
xử lý đơn nhất là gì? Là xn. Xn có nghĩa
là gì? X có nghĩa là bây giờ ấy khi mà
tôi có một cái category mới ôi sẽ mã h
một cái vecơ toàn số 0. Là xong đúng
không các bạn? Nhìn này. Mã một vectơ
toàn số 0 này. The result on hot and an
đấy on zeros. Được chưa? vectơ toàn số
0. Được chưa? Đây là cách đơn giản thứ
nhất. Còn đâu người ta có một vài cách
ví dụ người ta có thể mép nó thành một
cái giá trị mà
ít xuất hiện tức là nó sẽ map thành một
cái tức là nó coi đây là một tểu số nó
xem là ông nào thiểu số nhất nó nhét vào
đấy. Cách này người ta ít khi người ta
dùng được chưa? Tôi dùng cái xn xẽ sẽ
không bị lỗi nữa. Được chưa? Đây
ông này bây giờ cho đây location này
đúng không?
Anol bằng x no được chưa? X no như này.
Muốn chắc cú nữa thì nhét thêm cả cái
function ở dưới. Tôi cũng cho như thế
đúng không? Nó chắc cú để cho t nó đỡ bị
lỗi. Đây như này được chưa? Ch lại nhá.
Được chưa? Chở lại nó sẽ không bị lỗi
nữa. Bây giờ mà gặp những cái giá trị
như là Kentuky hoặc là MB nó sẽ thành
vecơ toàn 0 là sao? Được chưa? Coi như
chúng nó thành map thành cùng một cái
class mới, một cái category mới đúng
không?
Lại chờ lại chờ đúng chạy n hơi lâu
nhiều feature đúng không này có 100 cây
không khác gì chúng ta sẽ huấn luyện 100
mô hình cả nhá
đấy đây là qu trình huấn luyện đúng các
bạn không huấn luyện thì loanh quanh nó
cũng chỉ như thế thôi đúng không các bạn
thấy không đây là bài thứ ba chúng ta
code rồi các bạn thấy không loanh quanh
nó cũng chỉ có cái gì nó cũng chỉ có là
chúng ta ờ đọc dữ liệu vào đúng không có
thể là trải qua một vạch cái bước tiền
xử lý nho nhỏ xong cho tách dữ liệu theo
chiều dọc theo chiều ngang theo chiều
dọc là xong bên y sng bên chiều Chúng
ngang là x/ên x test y/ test thứ đúng
không? Sau đó chúng ta ừ chúng ta bắt
đầu chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu tiền xử lý. Tiền
xử lý này. Đấy tiền xử lý này được chưa?
Tiền xử lý xong cho bắt đầu chúng ta sẽ
ghép nó vào mô hình ghép nó vào mô hình
xong thì bắt đầu chúng ta sẽ huấn luyện
thôi. Fit cho đây đúng không? Huấn luyện
đây. Huấn luyện mô hình xong rồi đây mô
hình nó đi dự đoán. Dự đoán xong các bạn
in ra cái magic thế là xong. Nó đang nó
chỉ như vậy thôi đúng không? Ba bài rồi
nó cũng cái flow nó cũng chả khác gì
nhau cả. Có hơn nhau là chỉ đước cho
tiền xử lý. Mỗi bài nó sẽ khác nhau một
chút đúng không các bạn? Chờ chút chúng
ta chạy xong chúng ta sẽ nói xem là bây
giờ chúng ta muốn cải thiện mô hình
chúng ta cải thiện kiểu gì nhá.
Cái bài này mình dùng random forest tại
vì thế mình chưa có cái chưa có cái căn
cứ gì để biết dùng mô hình gì. Tại vì là
chúng ta cũng không có coration magic.
Chúng ta chúng ta cũng không biết là có
cái chuyện nào có hệ số tương quan lớn
với tit hay không đúng không? Mình c
dùng một cái mô hình tương đối phức tạp
tại vì dữ liệu dạng NP dạng dữ liệu
tương đối phức tạp mà đúng không?
Nói về dữ liệu các bạn nhá. Nói thêm một
tí trong lúc chờ các cái dữ liệu dữ liệu
dạng bản người ta gọi là dữ liệu có cấu
trúc structure data còn dữ liệu dạng văn
bản với cả ảnh với cả audio người ta dữ
liệu phi cấu trúc unstructure data được
chưa rượu có cấu trúc thì bao giờ cũng
rất là dễ và phi cấu trúc thì bao giờ
cũng sẽ khó hơn được chưa
hầu nhở xong rồi này
đây confusion matric hàng là thực tế cột
là dự đoán được chưa
ghi lại nhá Không tí nó lại chạy nó lại
mất lại mất công chạy lại
bạn nhìn nhá.
Đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Chúng ta có
chúng ta có
đây là cái a classification report đúng
không? Chúng ta có những cái class này.
Tất nhiên là tất nhiên là nhìn chung thì
class nào mà thường nó cn nó có nhiều
thông thường thông thường nó mà có nhiều
sample thì thường là cái magic nó sẽ tốt
hơn đúng không? Hôm này có nhiều sample
này. Re, rec là 96% F1 là 83% vân vân
đúng không? Acos tổng quát là 70%.
Chúng mình có có trọng sốở đây 68 70 64
này nó nhìn qua như này đúng không? Ông
nào mà có ít sample thì nó sẽ thường
điểm thấp thấp thôi đúng không? Nhìn qua
này
các bạn nhìn này. Nhìn qua nhá. Ông này
đúng không? 00 tức là nó cũng chả dự
đoán được cái gì đúng không? Ông này
cũng không đúng không? Thường các cái cá
thiểu số thì điểm thấp thôi. Nhưng mà ở
đây mình thấy có một cái điểm đặc biệt
này. Có cái điểm mình chú ý là gì? Các
bạn nhìn này,
cái class director business leader này
nó có 14 sample, nó rất là ít.
Bình thường là nhó ít này thì cái điểm
nào nó cũng phải thấp. Nhưng mà mình chú
ý này, cái điểm presion của nó lại đến 1
100%. Trong khi đến cái số nhất là ông
này nó cũng chỉ có 72% thôi. Có b nào
giải thích mình vì sao cái ông này từng
này sample nó chỉ có 72% trong khi ông
này có 14 đến 100% này phi lý nhở.
Vì sao?
Sao lại vô lý này?
Thấy phi lý không? Nó có 14 sle thôi. Nó
nó là một th số những class kiểu số. Sau
này nó đạt được cái pion tuyệt đối trong
khi các ông khác không đạt được này.
Ừ
ít hơn nên độ chính xác khó chuẩn xác
hơn. Nhưng mà ông này ít mà nó cao vút
này. Đây là 100% đấy. Đúng không? Đây là
100% đấy. Ông này có 14 sample mà được
pion 100%. Trong khi ông này 868 nó chỉ
được 72% thôi. Sao lại phi lý nhỉ? Nghe
nó không logic đúng không? Nghe không
logic.
Nào vì sao nhỉ? Vì sao một trong số
những cái lá thiểu số nó chỉ có 14 thôi
mà nó lại đạt được pi/ 100%.
Độ rất là cao đúng không? Rec thì thấp
không nói làm gì nhưng mà rec thấp thì
chuyện bình thường thôi thì nó là các
kiểu số mà nhưng mà ch rất cao. Vì sao?
Em nghĩ bài toán với cái class đó nó dễ
phân biệt lên mô đ học nhanh.
Có b nào hết cái hiện tượng này không
sạy xạy được 100% này nhỉ?
Precision mà cao ấy có nghĩa là dự đoán
ít sai đúng không? Cao đố này có nghĩa
là không sai luôn đúng không?
Rion mà cao này tức là gì? Dự đoán nó ít
sai. Chậm chí đây là không sai.
Các bạn cho mình hỏi này, sau này các
bạn đi làm ấy, các bạn đi làm các bạn
mới đi làm intern ở một công ty đúng
không? Các bạn làm việc các bạn cho mình
hỏi này, bây giờ mình làm việc mà mình
muốn là mình ít mắc lỗi, làm việc mà
muốn ít mắc lỗi thì có cái bí kíp gì
không các bạn?
Làm sao để các bạn làm việc các bạn ít
bị mắc lỗi? Cách dễ nhất là gì các bạn?
Làm ít. Đúng rồi, chính xác. Làm ít thôi
đúng không? Làm càng ít càng ít mắc lỗi.
Không làm thì không mắc lỗi nữa. Nhưng
mà ở đây không làm thì nó lại mọi số nó
sẽ bằng 0 hết. Đúng không? Thì các bạn
nhìn này, các bạn hiểu tưởng tượng này
tức là gì? Trong số 14 cái sample này ấy
có một cái tức là với cái class này ấy,
những cái class này thì mô hình nó sẽ
như này. Tức là khi nào mà cái dấu hiệu
nó rất là rõ ràng rồi có thể là trong
cái title nó có nguyên cả cái dòng chữ
này rồi hoặc là trong cái description nó
có nguyên nguyên dòng chữ này rồi. Tức
là khi mà nó rất là chắc chắn rồi, tức
là kèo rất là thơm rồi thì mô hình nó
mới đưa dự đoán. Còn đâu thì tất cả các
cái chuẩ khác nó cứ đưa dự đoán là cái
class khác là gì? Tránh động vào cái
class này đúng không? Chỉ khi nào mà rất
clear, rất rõ ràng, rất chắc chắn rồi
thì tôi mới động vào nó. Thì đấy là cái
bí kí để sao cho cái pion nó cao. Pion
cao có nghĩa là gì? Tức là tôi chỉ trong
số 1615 sample này, tôi chỉ đúng một lần
tôi đưa dự đoán là cái input là thuộc về
class này thôi. Tại vì tôi rất là chắc
chắn rồi, có thể input cái mô tả việc
rất là rõ ràng là cái này thô gì đấy
đúng không? Có các trường hợp khác thì
tôi không có dự đoán vào nó đúng không?
Càng ít đưa dự đoán thì ta càng ít sai.
Được chưa? Cũng không thể nào mà không
đưa dự đoán thì không đưa dự đoán nó sẽ
không không hết này. Được chưa? không
hết này. Đấy được chưa? Đúng 14 14 ông
chỉ tìm được một ông thôi. Nó 1/7 à tức
là 7% đúng không?
Đưa ra ít dự đoán thôi thì sẽ sai ít
đúng không?
Anyway thì đây là kết quả của chúng ta
được chưa? Kết quả nó được như thế này.
Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ các bạn nhìn này nhá. Các
bạn nhìn này. Thông thường thông thường
ý với những cái bài trước ý với những
cái bài trước khi mà chúng ta nói việc
là chúng ta cải thiện mô hình đúng
không? Hai cái bài trước khi nói chúng
ta cải thiện mô hình là các bạn mặc định
các bạn hiểu là mình đang muốn nói về
cải thiện cái magic ví dụ là cải cải cải
thiện
score recol hoặc thậm chí là acasiy đúng
không? Thông thường khi chúng ta nói về
cải thiện mô hình là chúng ta mặc định
chúng ta sẽ nghĩ luôn đến việc là cải
thiện magic aquasi vision rec f1 mean
square root mean up square root
coefficient of determination những cái
magic như vậy đúng không? Thế nhưng mà
sau này ấ khi mà các bạn đi làm ấy khi
mà tôi nói là tôi cải thiện tôi improve
cái gì đấy thì cái ý nghĩa đó nó sẽ rộng
hơn. Cái việc là cải thiện matri của mô
hình nó là một thứ. Ngoài ra sẽ còn rất
nhiều thứ khác các bạn phải cải thiện
hay người ta thường người ta không nói
là cải thiện sẽ nói là tối ưu. Tối ưu ví
dụ là gì? Ờ có thể ở trong các cái mô
hình machining nó sẽ chưa có rõ ràng
nhưng mà sau các bạn các bạn học tiếp
lên các bạn học về deep learning n các
bạn thể nói rõ hơn rất là nhiều.
Thì khi mà tôi nói về tối ưu mô hình ấy
thì tối ưu cái magic của mô hình nó chỉ
là tối ưu cái performance mô hình, tối
ưu cái magic nó chỉ là một khía cạnh
thôi. Các bạn sẽ cần phải tối ưu những
cái thành phần liên quan đến model
deployment, liên quan đến triển khai mô
hình. Thế thì khi mà triển khai mô hình
nó sẽ có những cái bài toán là gì? Cái
thời gian xử lý là bao lâu? Các bạn đưa
một cái input vào bao lâu các bạn nhận
được cái output đầu ra đúng không? Nó
rất là quan trọng. Tại vì sao? Các bạn
cứ tưởng tượng bây giờ các bạn sử dụng
cái mô hình làm sao nhận diện biển số xe
để các bạn lắp ở ngoài giao thông để nó
nhận diện biển số xe đúng không? Thế là
các cái tưởng hượng ấm xem bây giờ cái
ứng dụng mà nó dạy thời gian thực tức là
1 giây nó phải xử lý được tối thiểu là
25 khung hình. Thế bây giờ các bạn có
một cái mô hình OCA mà cái mô hình nhân
diện biểu xe nó rất là tốt thế nhưng mà
nó chạy chậm nó to mỗi giây mô hình nó
chỉ dưới được hai khung bình thôi thì
các bạn cũng không thể nào các bạn có
thể chuyển ngay trong thực tế được đúng
không? Tức là gì? Mô hình của tôi về mặt
performance nó rất là tốt và tôi không
thể nào tôi có thể tôi triển khai nó
trong thực tế được tại vì là nó chậm quá
đúng không? Mà chậm thường nó yêu nó
liên quan đến việc là mô hình nó lớn, nó
cồng kềnh, thời gian xử lý nó lâu có
đúng không? Nó bao gồm bao gồm những cái
thứ đấy nó cộng lại. Thế
với cái bài này chúng ta đã bắt đầu
chúng ta thấy manh nha có cái yếu tố thứ
hai rồi. Tức là hai cái bài trước chúng
ta chỉ liên quan đến performance thường
là liên quan đến magic thôi là xong.
Nhưng bài này nó bắt đầu có yếu tố thứ
hai là liên quan đến tốc độ xử lý rồi
đúng không? Các cái bài trước tốc độ xử
lý không phải vấn đề tại vì nó chạy rất
là nhanh nhưng bài này tốc độ xử lý nó
bắt đầu là một yếu tố mà các bạn có thể
các bạn cần phải quan tâm rồi đúng
không? Tại vì chạy lâu quá sau này phục
vụ người dùng họ đư vào thì làm sao mà
cứ mỗi một lần chạy hết mấy chục giây
này thì thì cũng hơi khó đúng không? Thế
nên đây tất nhiên đây mới chỉ là
training thôi. Trêning nó hơi lâu nhưng
mà ching lâu thì khả năng cao là chỉ
khai nó cũng sẽ lâu đấy đúng không?
Thế thì bây giờ giả sử tức là thông
thường nó sẽ có ba yếu tố là ờ matric,
memory và speed. Nhưng mà thường memory
speed nó hay đi cùng nhau. Thường là ông
nào chiếm nhiều memory chạy nó sẽ lâu và
ngược lại đúng không? Thế bây giờ mình
sẽ bỏ tạm thời mình bỏ qua cái memory
mình nói về speed thôi. Thế bây giờ các
bạn cho mình hỏi này, bây giờ khi mình
muốn tối ưu cái mồi này, mình muốn
optimize this model đúng không? Bây giờ
sẽ có hai yếu tố mình cần cân nhắc. Một
là magic. Ví dụ mình nói về ví dụ như là
các bạn có thể coi là cái wed average
chẳng hạn đúng không? Một là magic là
cái nhất. Hai là tốc độ xử lý, tốc độ
chạy, tốc độ huấn luyện. Có hai cái thứ
này để tối ưu. Thông thường chúng ta sẽ
không chúng ta có thể tối ưu cùng lúc
được. Chúng ta phải tối ưu từng thứ một,
đúng không? Giống như kiểu các bạn đi
học thế thôi. Thường các bạn phải tối ưu
từng môn một. Làm sao các bạn học tất cả
các thứ cùng tối ưu được đúng không? Thế
bây giờ theo các bạn với cái bộ với cái
bài toán này với cái bài toán job
classification này, theo các bạn bây giờ
giữa việc là tối ưu giữa việc tối ưu
matric trước và tối ưu tốc độ chạy
trước. Theo các bạn các bạn sẽ ưu tiên
các bạn tối ưu cái gì trước? Và lý do là
vì sao? Có hai cái.
Một là magric, hai là tốc độ xử lý. Các
bạn tối ưu cái nào trước?
V cái nào trước
tới magic trước hay là tới tốc độ xử lý
trước?
Magic tức là ví dụ như là F1 rec kiểu
kiểu như vậy. Tốc độ xí là tốc độ chạy
thôi.
Đây mình nói đúng về cái bài toán này
này. Mình đang trong quá trình huấn
luyện này. Mình vẫn đang trong quá trình
huấn luyện nhá. Mình mình chưa triển
khai. Mình vẫn chưa triển khai. Bây giờ
mình sẽ có hai từ tối ưu. Một là mình
tối ưu tốc độ xử lý. Hai mình tối ưu
magic. Tại vì thường tôi tố ưu magic thì
sau này các bạn test khả năng cao nó sẽ
tốt hơn. Tôi tốc độ xử lý sau này các
bạn triển khai nó khả năng t nó sẽ nhanh
hơn đúng không?
Các bạn tối yêu cái gì chưa?
Vì sao các bạn lại nghĩ là magic? Vì sao
các bạn lại nghĩ là tốc độ xử lý? Và lý
do là lý do là vì sao? Các bạn có thể
giải hết cho mình đâu. Vì sao các bạn
lại nghĩ là magic? Vì sao các bạn lại
nghĩ là speed?
Có ai thấy được không?
Thưa cái nào lý do là vì sao bạn giấy
được không? Vì sao các bạn chọn cái này
qua giấy được không?
Ừ. Thế lần này mình đặt mình nói về nói
về tốc độ đúng không? Sau triển khai cho
khách hàng. Khách hàng yêu cầu là phải
trong 1 giây phải xử lý được bao nhiêu
request đúng không? Bây giờ mình chạy
chậm quá thì cũng không ổn đúng không?
Chậm quá thì cũng không ổn.
Máy chị ok rồi cũng chưa chắc đúng
không? Mình cũng nhỡ đâu tí nữa mình có
thể tìm một cái mô hình máy chị nó còn
tốt hơn thì làm sao đúng không? Chỗ này
thì cũng ok đấy nhưng mà nhỡ đâu tí nữa
còn tốt hơn nữa thì làm sao đúng không?
Mình chưa biết được.
Mọi người xem với những cái gì chúng ta
đang có trong trong tay đúng không? Với
những thứ đ trong tay bây giờ mình có
hai đối tượng mình cần tối ưu. Một là
mình tối ưu performance tức là mình muốn
làm sao tìm xem làm sao kết quả nó tốt
hơn nữa đúng không? 68 70 mình muốn tăng
lỡ nữa lên hai mình tối ưu tốc độ nó sẽ
nhanh hơn. Theo các bạn tất nhiên mình
có thể làm cả hai nhưng mà thông thường
sẽ không bao giờ làm song song được. Các
bạn phải thử từng thứ một. Theo các bạn
các bạn sẽ ưu tiên các bạn tối ưu về
magic trước hay các bạn tối ưu về speed
trước.
Chúng ta sẽ không cần phải đ đánh đổi.
Chúng ta có thể tối ưu cả hai nhưng mà
thường nó sẽ không đồng thời được.
Tôi hưu cái nào chưa đây?
Nào cho mình một lý do nào. Các bạn chọn
magic hoặc các bạn chọn speak. Bạn cho
mình một lý do đi. Give me a reason.
Give me a reason.
Tôi m trước cốt lem
nghĩ là mic rồi em nghĩ tôi ưu tiên và
đổi chính xác trước
các bạn nhìn nhá
với cái bài này tất nhiên như mình nói
chúng ta sẽ tối Ví dụ cả hai cái
ư các bạn nhìn nhá với bài này nhá kinh
nghiệm cá nhân nhá kin cả nhân và thật
ra cái này đườ mình cũng làm như vậy mà
nhá không phải không phải mỗi mình đẻ ra
đâu các bạn này với những cái bài này ấy
các bạn nên tối ưu về tốc độ trước
tối ưu về tốc độ trước tại vì sao
các bạn tối ưu tốc độ trước có nghĩa là
gì có nghĩa là sau đó các bạn sẽ thử
được nhiều hơn
các bạn có thử Thử nghĩ mà xem nãy giờ
mỗi lần chạy xong chúng ta phải ngồi đợi
2 phút đúng không? Mà đây mới là machine
learning thôi. Sau các bạn sẽ có gặp về
deep learning nữa cơ đúng không? Nếu đây
là bài toán liên quan đến đánh đổi tức
là tôi chỉ chọn được cái này hoặc cái
kia thì ok. Tôi tập trung về magic là ok
đúng không? Tập trung về magic tại vì nó
là cái thứ mà chúng ta ưu tiên hơn.
Nhưng đây không phải thứ đánh đổi mình
nói rồi các bạn vẫn có thể các bạn nó
không phải như kiểu là pion với cả
recol. Prision rec là nó đánh đổi đưa
ông này mất ông kia. Còn magic với speed
là hai thứ các bạn vẫn có thể tăng cả
hai ông cùng cùng nhau được nhưng mà sẽ
không thử cùng lúc được. Tập trung từng
thứ một các bạn cứ thử nghĩ xem bây giờ
chạy một lần chờ mất 2 phút tức là 1
tiếng các bạn chỉ chạy được có 30 lần
thôi. Bây giờ nếu các bạn đổi các bạn
giảm được từ 2 phút thành 20 giây là
giảm nhanh gấp sáu lần rồi. Các bạn sẽ
thử được nhiều hơn. Thử được nhiều hơn
thì các bạn sẽ có thể có khả năng ra kết
quả tốt hơn. Có đúng không? Chứ các bạn
hôm nãy giờ ngồi ấn xong có phải cả thầy
cả trò ngồi nhìn nhau 2 phút mới ra kết
quả đúng không? Đúng không? Nó lâu đúng
không? Nó lâu. Thế thì chúng ta phải làm
sao cho cho nó nhanh hơn đúng không? Tất
nhiên nhanh hơn và phải đảm bảo là gì?
Nó không ảnh hưởng đến cái performance
chứ không phải là tôi nhanh hơn cho nó
movic nó drop thì không phải như vậy
đúng không? Chúng ta mà chạy nhanh hơn
ấy thì lập tức là chúng ta sẽ thử được
nhiều hơn đúng không?
Đúng không? Đấy là lý do đúng không? Đấy
lý do ra mình bảo các bạn là gì? Là với
bài này đúng không? Và sau này với những
trường hợp khác cũng như vậy thôi đúng
không? Nếu giữa các cái thứ mà không
phải đ không phải đánh đổi ấy đúng
không? không phải đánh đổi, tức là tôi
chọn mai tôi bỏ ông kia đúng không? Đây
là mình có thể chọn được cả hai thì mình
xem là cái ông nào nó giúp mình cái quá
trình nó trải nghiệm nó thoải mái hơn
đúng không? Bây giờ cứ mỗi lần ngồi chờ
2 phút thì nó lâu quá đúng không? Thế
bây giờ muốn cải thiện tốc độ chừ này
chạy chậm đến từ đâu các bạn? Cái chừ
này chạy chậm nó đến từ đâu? Nó đến từ
đâu? Nguyên nhân chính là từ đâu?
Nguyên nhân chính chạy chậm đến từ đâu?
Muốn tối ưu tốc độ phải chỉ ra cái chỗ
nó chạy chậm đã. Chậm là do đâu? Ở chỗ
nào?
Từ nhiều đúng nó nhiều feature quá. Nó
nhiều feature là do ông nào? Nó nhiều
feature đúng nó nhiều feature quá nó
nhiều feature là do ông nào? Là do
description chính xác. Tức là gì? Tức là
bây giờ tôi muốn xử lý tôi phải tập
trung vào cái description này trước đúng
không? Tại vì nó là cái nguyên nhân nó
khiến cho nhiều nhiều feature quá đúng
không? Nhiều feature quá. Được chưa? Thì
các bạn nhìn này, bây giờ chúng ta sẽ
chúng sẽ thử can thiệp một chút. Can
thiệp một chút. Thì các bạn để ý này,
với cái cột description này ấy, chúng ta
đã dùng TF IDF rồi. Về mặt bản chất thì
TF IDS nó sẽ gán cái số điểm khác nhau
cho các cái feature khác nhau đúng
không? Ông nào quan trọng thì điểm cao,
ông nào ít quan trọng thì điểm thấp thì
ok rồi đúng không? Nhưng các bạn tưởng
tượng này, dùng tiếp này nó cũng giống
như kiểu như này. Bây giờ cô giáo dạy
các bạn môn toán, cô có 100 bộ đề, cô
đưa cho các bạn 100 bộ đề, cô bảo là gì?
Trong 100 bộ đề này, đề từ số 1 đến số
10 là quan trọng nhiều. Các bạn tập
trung ôn. Đề số từ 11 đến đề số 100 ít
quan trọng ôn ít thôi, đúng không? Thì
cô đưa cho các bạn như thế thì tất nhiên
các bạn biết là 10 cái bộ đầu nó quan
trọng, các bạn tập trung rồi. Nhưng mà
90 cái bộ kia các bạn vẫn sẽ phải dành
một chút sự quan tâm đến chúng nó. Có
đúng không? Mặc dù đúng là cái trọng số
nó thấp rồi nhưng các bạn vẫn phải dành
một chút sự quan tâm đến chúng đúng
không? Tức là cái attention của bạn nó
bị chia sẻ bớt đi rồi đúng không? Thế
bây giờ thay vì như vậy, bây giờ nếu mà
cô giáo bỏ luôn 90 cái đề kia, cô chỉ
bảo các bạn tập trung 10 đề này thôi thì
các bạn sẽ totally focus vào 10 cái đề
đấy, đúng không? Thì ở đây ý tưởng cũng
là như vậy. Bây giờ ấy trong cái chỗ này
các bạn nhớ với chúng ta tính ra thì
riêng cái riêng cái cột description này
nó phải ra đến 600 hay là 800 bao nhiêu
nghìn
nghìn nghìn token trong cái vocabary
đúng không? Bao gồm cả unigram và bogram
đúng không? nó rất là nhiều nhưng mà
phần lớn chúng nó sẽ gần như nó đóng vai
trò rất là ít. Thì bây giờ ấy tôi sẽ tôi
biết là những cái ông này điểm sẽ điểm
nó sẽ thấp rồi nhưng mà nếu tôi để nó ở
đấy mô hình nó vẫn phải dành một số một
một chút sự chú ý đến những cái fit đến
những cái token này. Thì bây giờ thay vì
tôi vẫn cứ để như vậy tôi sẽ bỏ nó đi
luôn. Tôi bỏ điế nào thì có một quy rất
là đơn giản các bạn nhìn nhá.
Nhìn lại cái TFID này. Bây giờ tôi có
hai cái tham số rất là quan trọng. Nó
giúp cho các bạn có thể các bạn chủ động
các bạn can thiệp các bạn lọc bớt
feature đi thay vì để cho mô hình thay
vì chờ cái tiếp IDF nó gắn cái điểm thấp
trong này thì các bạn chủ động loại bỏ
luôn. Cái chữ DF ở đây nó tương đương
với cái gì? Nó tương đ cái document
frequency. Tần số của document tức là
gì? Tức là bây giờ ấy ví dụ về cái min
df trước, bây giờ ấy khi mà tôi sử dụng
vocaby tôi sẽ bỏ luôn những cái token
nào mà nó có cái document frequency nó
dưới một cái ngưỡng nào đấy. Cái này thì
thường người ta sẽ dùng số thực như là
số nguyên. Số nguyên thì người ta ít khi
dùng ví dụ dùng số thực là 0,0,01 đi.
0,01 là 1% tức là gì? Tức là những cái
token nào xuất hiện dưới 1% tổng số
lượng document tôi sẽ loại đi. Được
chưa? Token nào xuất hiện dưới 1% tổng
số lượng document tôi sẽ loại bỏ tất cả
những token này đi. Tại vì nó ít quá mà
đúng không? Bộ truyề của mình có khoảng
60 65.500 document đúng không? Thì bây
giờ 1% là khoảng 65 document tức là bây
giờ cái token nào xuất hiện dưới 65
document tôi sẽ bỏ luôn. Nó ít quan
trọng quá đúng chưa? Tương đương với
cũng là MDF.
Mdf thì là cái cận trên đúng ông nào
xuất hiện nhiều ông nào xuất ít quá thì
tôi bỏ đành. Ông nào xuất nhiều quá cũng
thế thôi. Ông nào xuất hiện ví dụ trên
99% nó chả có ý nghĩa gì cả. Thấy bỏ đi.
Được chưa? Đây là hai cái thứ giúp bạn
các bạn để các bạn chủ động các bạn lọc
bớt đi những cái token nào mà nó ít quan
trọng. Xuất hiện ít quá cũng ít quan
trọng. Xuất hiện nhiều quá cũng ít quan
trọng. Thì sao? Xuất hiện ít quá thì cái
điểm TF nó sẽ thấp. Xuất hiện nhiều quá
thì cái điểm IDF nó sẽ thấp đúng không?
Thì một trong hai không thấp thì bây giờ
tôi bỏ đi luôn cho mô hình không cần
phải nghĩ đến nó nữa. Được chưa? Thường
ta sẽ dùng float
nó sẽ dễ hơn. Dùng in các bạn phải chỉ
ra cụ thể là xuất hiện bao nhiêu dụ đấy.
Min là để 50 ta dưới 50 lần max là
2000 chẳng hạn nó suy trên 2000 lần.
Mình thường ta dùng số thực nó sẽ dễ
hơn. Thế các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ mình
các bạn thử này. Thì lúc trước ấy mình
kết hợp unigram với đúng không? Thì tôi
có tổng cộng là 848.000 này mà chỗ này
là kết hợp cả ba ông với nhau à cả năm
ông này với nhau đúng không? Bây giờ
mình sẽ thêm cái min với max df nhá.
Được chưa? Min df này. Ví dụ min df bằng
0,01 tức là 1% đó đúng không?
Max DF bằng 0,99 đi. Được chưa? Là 99%
được chưa? Bây giờ trước khi mình chạy
cái pipeline này mình sẽ xem thử xem thử
xem là bây giờ nếu mà mình ờ chạy thử
cái t bức tử xỉ này thì nó sẽ tạo ra bao
nhiêu feature nhá. Được chưa? Lúc đầu
tôi chưa can thiệp min viên maf tôi có
848.000 token tổng cộng đúng không? Bây
gi tôi chạy thử này. Chạy thử này.
Đó mình chỉ cệt đúng một chỗ thôi đúng
không? Thêm hai cái này. Một cái chặn
dưới một cái chặn trên đúng không? Xuất
xuất hiện dưới 1% tổng sự document tôi
cũng bỏ và xuất hiện trên 99% tôi cũng
bỏ. Được chưa?
Đây các bạn nhìn này. Nó coi có từng này
được chưa?
cộng min df cộng với max df được chưa nó
còn từ này
nhỏ hơn rất là nhiều đúng không số lượng
các bạn từ 848.000 000 đ giảm đi hơn 100
lần được chưa? Giảm đi hơn 100 lần
đúng không? Số lượng vure giảm đi thì
chả cần chạy cũng biết chắc chắn là gì
là chúng ta chạy quá trình chêning này
nó sẽ tiêu tốn ít tài nguyên máy tính
hơn, ít memory hơn, ít RAM hơn và chạy
sẽ nhanh hơn đúng không? Chưa chạy tôi
cũng thừa biết rồi đúng không? X đồ b nó
ít hơn mà 100 cái cây nó sẽ ít phức tạp
hơn sẽ nhanh hơn đúng không? Thế nhưng
thế nhưng cái việc mà chúng ta can thiệp
này ấy, cái việc mà chúng ta giảm bớt số
lượng feature để giúp cho mô hình nó
chạy nhanh hơn, tiêu tốn ít t nguyên hơn
ấy nó sẽ chỉ thực sự có ý nghĩa khi nào.
Nó sẽ chỉ thực sự có ý nghĩa khi nào
chúng ta làm giảm số lượng feature giúp
chúng ta tiê tốn ít tài nguyên hơn, chạy
nhanh hơn. Nó sẽ chỉ thực sự có ý nghĩa
khi nào?
Khi mà performance của mô hình nó làm
sao?
Khi mà performance của mình nó làm sao?
Nào, cái việc giảm bớt số lượng future
tiêu tốn ít tài nguyên hơn, chạy nhanh
hơn, nó sẽ chỉ thực sự có ý nghĩa khi mà
performance của mô hình nó làm sao các
bạn. Bạn khác bạn Hiếu đi.
Cao chung chung mà bao nhiêu thì là cao
không ảnh hưởng nhiều nó vẫn chung chung
quá
ảnh hưởng có nhiều loại ảnh hưởng lắm.
Nào cái việc làm giảm phụ giảm phụ vườn
này đúng không? giảm tài nguyên thính
toán, giảm memory tăng tốc độ xử lý. Nó
sẽ chỉ thực sự có ý nghĩa khi mà
performance của mô hình nó làm sao các
bạn
dễ lắm các bạn suy nghĩ logic thôi. Suy
nghĩ logic thôi,
không thay đổi lắm. Ư
not really không phải
nào
cực kỳ dễ suy nghĩ logic của các bạn
giống như kiểu cái trường hợp vấy cô cô
thay vì các bác học bác bác các bạn học
100 đề bây giờ cô chỉ bắt các bạn học 10
đề thôi đúng không để cho các bạn tập
trung vào hơn thì cái việc này nó chỉ
thực sự có ý nghĩa khi nào
không bị rope chưa mình vẫn chưa thấy có
bạn nào nói đủ ý
MIT không th ban đầu nhiều vẫn chưa để ý
vẫn chưa có một bạn nào nói đủ ý cho
mình ạ. Rất đơn giản kết luận cực kỳ đơn
giản luôn.
Việc chúng ta
giảm bớt sụi feature đúng không? Giúp
cho mô hình nó chạy nhanh hơn, tiêu tốn
ít tài nguyên hơn. Chạy nhanh hơn, ít
tài nguyên hơn nó sẽ chỉ có thực sự có ý
nghĩa nếu mà magic hay là performance
của mình nó làm sao.
Rất dễ suy nghĩ logic thôi các bạn ạ.
Rất dễ. nó làm sao
nó làm sao rất dễ các bạn.
Hoặc không phải hoặc là nó tốt lên đúng
không? Hoặc là trí làm sao là nó bằng
đúng không? Tốt lên hoặc bằng đúng
không? Hoặc là có thể gì? Có thể nó giảm
một chút không đáng kể đúng không?
Đúng không? tốt lên được thì là tốt
không thí chi trí cũng phải bằng hoặc
nếu giảm đừng có giảm nhiều quá ví dụ
chạy nhanh gấp năm lần trong khi giảm
0,01% thì cũng chấp nhận được đúng
không? Có đúng không? Chứ không phải là
các bạn cứ giảm feiture là mô hình nó sẽ
tồi đi đâu đúng không? Không phải là cứ
giảm feiture là mô hình nó sẽ tồi đấy
đâu. Có thể là các bạn giảm pure mô hình
còn tốt hơn. Tại vì sao? Mình nó tập
trung vào những ông quan trọng mà đúng
không? Không phải là tôi giảm feature đi
là auto là nó sẽ sẽ tôi đi đâu. Nó cũng
không auto là nó sẽ tốt hơn. Nó có thể
thay đổi nhưng cái việc này nó chỉ có ý
nghĩa là gì? Một là cho mình tốt hơn,
hai là bằng ba là gì? Nó có giảm đi thì
nó đừng có giảm nhiều quá. Giảm trong
mức chấp nhận được có đúng không? Thế
đây nhá. Đây là mình giảm s feature rồi
đúng không? Bây giờ mình test thử xem là
liệu nó giúp thay đổi mô hình như thế
nào đúng không? Bây giờ sẽ tắt chỗ này
đi. Được chưa? Tắt chỗ này đi. Tôi sẽ
chạy tiếp phần dưới này nhá. Xem nó thay
đổi như nào nhá. Được chưa? Tôi hy vọng
là gì? Là một là nó tốt hơn, hai là nó
bằng không thì chí là nó giảm. Đừng có
giảm nhiều quá. Được chưa? Chạy thử này.
Chạy thử này. Chắc chắn chạy sẽ nhanh
hơn đúng không? Chắc chắn là chạy sẽ
nhanh hơn. Nhưng mà tôi muốn xem là nó
ảnh hưởng nào đến kết quả chưa?
Nó mới thêm mỗi một chỗ thôi đúng không?
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Đúng chắc chắn nó
nhanh hơn không khỏi phải tính. Tại vì
do số lượng feature nó giảm đi mà đúng
không các bạn? Nhìn này. À tốn ít tài
nguyên hơn nhá. Các bạn nhìn so về magic
này. Đây dưới này là các bạn thấy nào?
Sau khi chúng ta bớt đi khoảng hơn 100
lần số lượng độ feature các bạn thấy nào
các bạn?
Thấy nào? Trên là cũ, dưới là mới.
Thế nào các bạn?
Tốt hơn đúng không?
Ít feature hơn, mô hình đơn giản hơn
chạy nhanh hơn.
Performance tốt hơn. Được chưa? Tất cả
mọi thứ đều hơn đúng không? Đây này. 68
lên 73 70 lên 75 lên 71 đúng không? Acua
cũng tăng đúng không? Cái gì cũng hơn
đúng không? Mà mình chạy nhanh hơn nữa
đúng không? Lúc đầu các bạn thấy không?
Lúc đầu có từng này bây giờ còn có từng
này thôi mà tôi chỉ đây tôi mới chỉ can
thiệp ở một chỗ thôi. Được chưa? Đây
chính là một đúng không? Đây là một cách
để chúng ta có thể tăng được performance
của mô hình đúng không? Không phải bao
giờ nhiều feature cũng tốt đúng không?
nhiều feature là thông tin nhưng mà
không phải cứ càng nhiều thông tin thì
càng tốt. Thông tin nó phải hữu ích đúng
không?
Đây mới một chỗ thôi. Được chưa? Tôi mới
chỉ can thiệp một chỗ thôi. Tôi mới chỉ
can thiệp với cod description thôi. Bốn
của kia tôi chưa đợi động gì. Được chưa?
Máy tập về nhà. Từ đây các bạn thử nghĩ
xem là chúng ta còn cái gì chúng ta có
thể làm để chúng ta cải thiện
performance của mô hình nhá. Đây mình
chỉ can thiệp có một chỗ thôi. Còn rất
nhiều chỗ khác có thể can thiệp được
đúng không? Tất nhiên các bạn có thể
dùng green search các thứ nữa. Rất nhiều
option nữa đúng không? Mọi người thử
nghĩ xem là theo các bạn bây giờ với cái
pip này tôi còn có cái việc gì tôi có
thể làm để tôi có thể cải thiện
performance của mô hình nhá. Đây là bài
tập về nhà. Ok.
Thứ nhất là các bạn cố gắng các bạn sao
các bạn code lại cái script này theo ý
của bạn. Các bạn không cần giống cha
mình. Các bạn có thể sử kiểu khác đi
cũng không vấn đề gì đúng không? Và sau
khi code xong rồi các bạn hiểu rồi thì
các bạn làm sao các bạn thử thách xem là
bây giờ tôi còn cái gì tôi có thể làm
tôi có thể cải thiện performance của mô
hình nhá. Cải thiện performance cũng là
cải thiện mà cải thiện tốc độ cũng là
cải thiện nhá. Cải thiện cái gì cũng là
cải thiện. Ok.
Ok. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Thế nhá. Được chưa? Có bạn nào có bất kỳ
thắc mắc gì các bạn có thể ấn mình trên
Zalo các bạn nhá. Ok. Rất là cảm ơn mọi
người. Tuần sau chúng sẽ học bình thường
thôi nhá. Tuần sau sẽ không có nghỉ gì
đâu nhá. Tuần sau học đủ hai buổi nhá.
Ok.
Ok. Cảm ơn mọi người nhá. Tuần sau lại
gặp lại các bạn nhá.
Bye mọi người nha.
Mọi người nha.
Mình sẽ up cho các bạn record luôn nhá.
Mình sẽ up cho các bạn cả cái script này
nữa nhá.